Ready?
Um,
four,
three,
two,
one,
boom.
And we're live.
You would just tell me,
you would just tell me how you son is getting into Bruce Lee because we were
looking at this,
uh,
shout out to,
how do you pronounce his name correctly?
Bruce Lee?
No,
play the plastic cell.
The plastic cell.
Dude,
I only seen it written and you have to to actually made it,
but yet plastic sell I believe is the name.
But I mean,
how do you pronounce the artist's name?
I think was the Phong Tran.
Yeah.
Shout out to phone.
This thing is the shit.
His art is amazing.
These little plastic cell things like Rory Macdonald.
How great is at the whole lineups?
Amazing.
Yeah.
I mean those are sunglasses,
which I'm off.
Nothing but legend today.
But yeah,
I wanted,
how old's your son now?
He's six now.
And
you hear these stories.
I'm constantly about people remembering the first time they saw Bruce Lee movie.
It's so epic.
I'll never forget my dad took me to the theater,
blew my mind.
Everyone's got a story.
Joe,
he's got his first time he saw Bruce Lee.
So I wanted to make sure I didn't do that too early because then he would
forget,
you know,
cause he forgets special last moments we had together from like three years ago.
I'm like,
I don't remember that,
you know,
cause he's the only five,
right,
man,
he's six [inaudible] six six.
Imagine how quick your brain is growing and the amount of money,
you forgot a lot of shit,
you know.
But anyways,
uh,
so I thought maybe I'm going to hit him with the,
I'm going to sit them down and,
and,
and put on,
enter the dragon and blow his fucking mind.
But I don't want to do a tour.
Like,
when do I do it?
I'm thinking maybe I could even wait till these 10 or eight or whatever,
you know?
But he's been doing karate since he was three,
so about three years now he's been doing karate and he took a nun,
chuck workshop class that they had.
So he's got his little,
you know,
those padded nun chucks.
He fucking loves those things,
man.
And I thought,
shit,
he's getting into the nun chucks.
It might be a time to drop Bruce Lee on his ass.
You know what I mean?
I don't want them to get twisted,
you know what I mean?
Cause he starts,
he starts talking about Jackie Chan and shit like that.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I guess you seen anybody do it on video or only learned it from a glisten.
This is what happened.
So He's,
he's all Linden and Chuck's,
he's beaten me up with them all the time.
He loves nunchucks and I,
and I said,
Oh,
then I wore one of those routes of fights shirts and it was Bruce Lee with lunch
looks right.
And he looked at my shirt and he said,
Daddy,
who's the guy with the nunchucks?
And I thought,
okay,
it's time.
It's time,
son.
Sit down.
So you know,
kids are so easily brainwashed.
I can get my kid into satanism.
We've seen this little kid.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's amazing.
He's got the Bruce Lee outfit,
I everything,
the jumpsuit,
this is amazing.
And he's got,
he's got,
uh,
the game of death sequence down.
It says the video is my son.
And in parentheses,
a five year acting.
Bruce Lee's nunchucks a scene.
Yeah,
he ran acts,
the whole thing.
No for not.
I think he was on like America's got talent or some shit too.
So I sat him down and I,
and I explained to him,
I go the master of the nun chucks the number one guy,
you know,
cause like,
like I was like I was saying earlier,
you could get kids to believe in anything.
You get brain.
I could,
I could get my son into Satan easily.
He'd be all in all about Lucifer.
Boom.
I got them under the Brown twigs.
Yeah.
Little kids.
Yeah,
totally.
He's,
he's so into the Dodgers because his grandpa is under the daughter,
so he's all about the Dodgers and I got them into the browns is all in the
Brown's not too because then I could get them into anything.
Right.
So I sat them down and I say,
you are,
but I'm going to sit you down and I'm going to show you the master of the
nunchucks in it's Bruce Lee.
He's number one dude.
He's the guy,
he's the greatest martial artist of all time.
I broke him and I sat him down and put them in front of the TV to that.
You should have filmed this.
I did you fill the whole thing?
He filmed you saying it to him?
No,
I didn't film that,
but I filmed it.
I filmed him watching Bruce Lee.
Um,
uh,
first I showed them the greatest nunchuck scenes of all time with Bruce Lee that
you can go to youtube and you can get,
there's compilations.
They put together the one from the stuff in enter the dragon and the stuff in a
Chinese connection,
uh,
way of the dragon or,
or return of the Dragon.
And uh,
so I sat them down and go,
I'm going to blitz them with this shit.
I'm going to make sure that whenever he thinks about fucking nunchucks he knows
that Bruce Lee's the master.
Right.
So he's just completely blown away.
Then after I showed him all the nunchucks scenes,
I sat them down and I wanted to show him the greatest fights of all time.
Bruce leave versus Chuck fucking Norris come on that.
So I just want her to leave that just in his DNA.
And I filmed that.
I filmed him watching,
uh,
Chuck Norris and Bruce Lee.
And he always wants to know he,
he loves,
he loves Bruce Lee instantly and he,
he,
he needs to know who wins the fight.
So it's like daddy does Bruce Lee when I go,
he always,
when sunny always wins and,
but my natural reaction,
cause he,
he's constantly asking questions.
He's constantly does.
He went,
my natural reaction would be just watch,
watch you gotta watch this because it's going to be sweeter if you watch it and
you go through the ups and downs.
And he goes,
no,
Daddy,
you need to tell me now.
And I go,
no,
you're going to like it more if you just watch it.
You got to know daddy does Bruce Lee when he wants to fucking know he going to
be disappointed.
Yeah.
So he got two years old.
He got completely blown away.
So a week later,
a week later I got today,
you're going to watch the greatest martial arts movie of all time and or the
dragon.
Cause it's Bruce Lee.
Dad,
isn't it?
I go,
yes,
it's
so we sat him down.
We put on for any,
can't stop asking fucking questions about every God.
Okay Daddy,
who are the good guys and who are the bad guys?
Is he a bad guy or is he a good guy?
So we got it down to three main good guys.
You know,
Bruce Lee is the main good guy.
Uh,
Williams.
I was um,
uh,
goddammit.
His name escapes me.
The black famous martial artists.
Jim Kelly,
Jim Keltner.
Wow.
I forgot about Jim.
Jim Kelly's awesome.
And uh,
he did die in the movie,
which I mean they were doing that shit back then.
You know what I mean?
A good guy.
And then roper,
John Saxon,
he was the third.
Good God.
Yes,
it was Roper Williams and Bruce Lee.
And they were all,
they were the good guys and the bad guys.
Do you remember the bad guys' names?
No.
Han was the,
the,
the dude on the top left.
He's the,
he's the guy with the clause,
former Shaolin monk who when bad and started selling heroin on this island and,
and,
and uh,
prostitution rings and all that Shit.
Completely forgot the plot of this movie.
Are you kidding me?
It's the greatest fucking plan.
I remember watching it,
but you know,
I didn't take it seriously.
I always thought it was fun.
I was,
I was looked at it and not like,
Holy Shit,
we're going to see this wild action movie.
I always thought of it is because by the time I watched it,
it was kind of campy mean.
I'm sure watching when I was a little kid,
you gotta don't remember.
Yeah.
You got to go back and watch the little thing.
Cause every wouldn't,
you know,
that's,
that's most people's common reaction.
Like you just remember,
you remember the scene with Han with the razor hand.
Remember he had to raise her hand.
He had a claw hand.
You remember Bolo young and they're fighting outside and the tournament,
you know,
you remember all that shit.
You remember?
Um,
uh,
Williams getting killed.
They hung them.
Uh,
your,
you remember Williams fighting,
Hon?
There's certain scenes everyone will remember and you've just,
you forget about the little scenes and the plot.
So I sit down to my son,
I sat down my son and we're watching this and my mom,
his mom's like,
it's appropriate for,
for a six year old,
right?
It's not going to get too crazy.
I go,
it's fine.
It's just a bunch of karate.
No,
it's fine.
So she's all like,
oh.
So we're sitting there and he can't stop asking God damn questions.
He can't stop asking God to him questions.
The bad guys are Hahn's the main guy,
oh,
Hora Bob Wall.
Remember him?
Everybody remembers he had a scar on his face and they,
everyone remembers that he was,
him and his gang were chasing Bruce Lee sister in the movie and they cornered
her and she had to kill herself.
She just killed herself before they could like rape or whatever.
People are what people remember that that's a another classic scene.
But you don't remember.
You don't think about all the shit in between man.
Cause the plot,
the plot of the story is Han lives on an island and he has,
he does a lot of illegal shit.
He runs a heroin and prostitution through his island,
right.
And,
um,
he has a tournament like once a year and he invites all the greatest martial
artists,
um,
on earth and he tries to recruit them.
He sits them all down and he,
and he shows them his,
uh,
like underground operation going on,
you know what I mean?
So he tried to Tom Roper into it.
He tried to talk Williams into an era and a roper almost went for it cause he
was a kind of,
he's a good guy,
but he was like a Gambler,
you know what I mean?
He's kind of shady,
but at the end he's like,
fuck this,
I'm going to do this shit.
So that's what he doesn't,
and he called him Bruce Lee to,
uh,
and he was going to try to recruit Bruce Lee,
but the CIA got ahold of Bruce Lee first.
Yes.
Seriously.
So they get ahold of Bruce Lee and they sit them down in a dark room and they're
playing a projector and they're showing,
you know,
uh,
they want Bruce Lee to go in there undercover to uncover all the,
um,
uh,
the,
the crime and all this stuff that was going on.
Selling drugs.
Yes.
Drugs and prostitution and um,
and doing mind control on a,
so what,
so I'm sitting there and watching it and he wants to know who the bad guys are.
Bolo Bolo is a bad guy.
O'Hara who's Bob Wall's a bad guy.
And then Hans,
the main bad guy.
So he's constantly ask some questions and then boom,
you forget about the scenes were um,
uh,
Han would,
has like a madam and he's got all these hookers and there's a hooker seen you
forget about the hooker scene.
They send like five girls to Williams who was a good guy in roper to try to
corrupt them,
you know what I mean?
And Boom,
as soon it,
they're all in their gowns and,
and in robes and Williams is like in our,
in a robe.
And I grabbed the remote and just started hitting fast forward.
And,
uh,
my son's a Lou,
what's going on here?
What's going on here,
dad?
Why you fast?
Where I'm glad nothing's going on.
What are they doing?
They're getting ready to go to sleep.
Just forget about that same boom.
And you forget that there's a,
is this the same?
There it is right there and there's titties and everything,
but um,
yeah,
he got,
he was blown away and a mission accomplished.
He's,
he's Bruce Lee's number one in,
uh,
to him and,
but I made a mistake the next week and I made them sit down and watch return of
the dragon,
which the end seeing was a great scene with Chuck Norris and the old Rome
Colosseum.
But the whole movie before that is so bad.
It's so bad.
And Bruce Lee directed it and uh,
and wrote it and it was,
uh,
it's atrocious.
It's so bad
except for the chuck.
So together except for the end,
but it's like high school kids put together that terror.
I going to have to go back a while.
We know we should do,
we should do a fight companion
and watch enter the dragon.
That would be fucking great dude.
Are you kidding?
Come on man.
Fight companion and watch this.
Look at this scene.
So there it's takes place in Italy.
His
uh,
one of his like think his uncle or just,
or just somebody he knows has a Chinese restaurant in Italy and the Italian mob.
These guys,
these are the goons.
They're trying to run them out of business and,
and uh,
control their business or pay Pam off to take the building or something.
And they're,
they're resisting in Italy.
So they send a Bruce Lee from Hong Kong to handle the mob to this.
It's so corny.
It's fucking bad.
So what do you think happened?
I think Bruce,
who's his partying too much,
doing a little blow,
having a good time out in the town,
being a big Hollywood star puts the of this movie and you just got a little
crazy with it.
You know what?
This is before he blew up though,
because he did this movie,
he did a big boss,
Chinese connection and this one was his third one.
And then after this is when Warner brothers came in and signed them.
That's when they did enter the dragon.
That was his last one.
Enter the dragon was uh,
had a,
had a budget,
this and that.
I'm really any budget.
This is a like just cheap Chinese production.
You know?
It's crazy when you think that there was really no one like him before him,
but there's Chuck Norris waiting,
waiting for him.
Thumbs down.
You know,
when you,
when you think about w there,
there was no kind of movies like this before.
This,
this fight scene.
Greatest fight scene,
worst movie.
How about the grab of the chest hair pulls a chunk of it out.
Oh Shit.
I got your chest hair,
bitch.
I mean it's,
it's funny watching it when no volume two because it's so corny.
It looks so fresh and it's all overdubbed and,
and it's,
it's God awful.
But dude,
his martial arts technique,
especially when you think about the fact that this was what,
1974,
that was like 71 71.
It was finally released in 76,
but he died in [inaudible] 73.
He had incredible technique,
like really good technique.
Like he's kicking technique especially for back then.
You know,
I think uh,
because of the youtube and shit,
there's,
there's so many guys out there that they're doing like,
um,
these jump spinning three wheel kicks.
There was some guy that more Winkle John Jackson had on his uh,
um,
the uh,
Instagram page and it's uh,
a Korean gentleman doing some fucking ridiculous shit.
Just like jumping 360 degree wheel kicks and like a series of them cartwheels
flying through the air and doing all these things.
Like none of this was ever in the movies before,
you know,
until like when like maybe gently I guess.
No on Bach.
Right.
Cause they're there a next level in terms of like athleticism.
I mean there's that Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon.
I mean it's all like mystical,
magical show.
This guy is actually doing this.
This is just a video of him.
He starts out normal stores,
like a bunch of front kicks,
throws a bunch of sidekicks,
and then he starts doing jumping wheel kicks,
three 60 wheel kicks,
tornado kicks.
He's just fucking flying through the air and flipping through the air.
Aerial cartwheel kicks and you're like,
Whoa,
people can do shit now.
And they do stuff in like in martial arts films,
the techniques,
just way better.
They're just way back.
He just got better at it.
Can you put that,
that fight something the backup.
But Bruce Lee and Chuck Norris,
see if you could sign that video first while you're looking for w just while
we're come out with the one.
That's the one thing about Bruce Lee.
All the pads and he flies.
No,
no,
no.
It's just a guy throwing kicks in the air.
He's just throwing kicks in the air.
It's on,
uh,
the Jackson wink.
Yeah,
it's Jackson.
Winkeljohn.
I just looked at her Instagram page.
Oh,
this guy's doing it an MMA?
No,
no.
He's doing it in the air.
I just doing it in the air.
Which of their pages should I,
is he planning to use it in them?
May Top one.
Jackson wink,
MMA.
That one.
Check that one out.
There's a Korean dude.
If you keep going down,
I don't know if he's planning on using in MMA.
Oh my fuck is it?
God Damn it.
I didn't see anything.
Maybe they were commenting on it.
Fuck somebody had it up.
Sorry.
Anyway,
but with Bruce Lee fight scenes,
what I like about them is you could see him,
although you know him beating up 50 guys at a time,
you know,
you know how real can that be.
But he does one on one on one fights.
He does a lot of bank team.
He'll do boxing stuff,
he'll do wrestling,
he'll do Jujitsu.
You see him mix it up and he's trying to make it,
uh,
a lot more realistic,
like the,
you know,
then you have your classic comfort with theater type movies where they just,
right.
You're like,
yeah,
that shit is just always a,
so Bruce Lee,
Bruce Lee,
we'll dance around,
he'll throw a jab fade,
kick you in the leg for fake low,
go high.
And knock you out.
He does that against the Chuck Norris.
Yeah.
In in a way or the dragon.
And if you go back to 1970,
like that kind of martial art technique and he was,
he was amazing.
He was also the first guy that figured out how to put a bunch of martial arts
together and just forget about,
um,
judo,
your karate and forget about that.
Just,
just,
just use everything that works.
Everything from everywhere.
And that was heresy back then.
I mean,
he might've been,
um,
uh,
he may have been the first guy to do that.
Really?
I mean,
for sure one of them for sure.
Yeah.
He's without a doubt.
Like I think there's two arguably to the most important figures ever in martial
arts.
I think he might be number one.
And the other one is Elio.
Gracie.
Okay.
You really think about it.
It's one guy tries to figure out how to beat men who are bigger than him,
has a bunch of kids.
They all turn out to be fucking savage.
Killer.
Yeah.
I mean,
what are the odds?
Yes.
The craziest family of all time.
Craziest family of all
time.
And if you think about it crazy in a good way.
Crazy.
We're getting the best way possible with a hundred percent respect.
I mean Hixon hallways Heuler Helson you know what the fuck.
And then there's different sides.
The Gracies had,
uh,
you know,
conflict within each other.
Crazy.
A family of soup.
Then employees,
who's another,
I mean it's,
it's almost like hoist,
although it came from Eylea,
he's almost as important.
If he doesn't win that first ultimate fighting championship,
we though we don't get the same impact he has to win.
Imagine if he would've lost the first fight.
What if you've got a head kicked?
You know what?
If you got in there with some guy who's done this before and he gets head
kicked,
Patrick Smith could have fucked him up.
Fucked up.
That we could have been if the lineups were different.
That could,
are you kidding?
The hoist Gracie movie and it ends after UFC to ends.
The Patrick Smith,
that's the perfect ending right there.
Did he ever got,
he fought Patrick Smith didn't wait for boys fight.
He chose to come up,
choked him or her the second time they were in the UFC together?
No,
it was the first one.
Yeah,
no,
it was UFC two voice was on one side of the bracket.
Pat Smith,
who's on the other side,
you know,
black,
uh,
you know,
killer Muy Thai guy.
Fucking like what he did to a Scott Morris Ninja guy.
Yeah,
dude,
man,
that's a movie.
That's a movie right there.
UFC Two with a goddamn movie.
Well,
Patrick Smith was a real legit top level kickboxer but he was a real dangerous
kickboxer you watch his striking.
I mean that guy was explosive,
super powerful and ruthless man.
What he got on top of that dude was elbowing him into oblivion.
Backlund they didn't know exactly when to stop a fight.
They weren't sure where to go.
John was like,
the guy is still alive.
Yeah.
But,
but the point is a hoist did when he didn't get kicked,
took the guys down,
choked him,
Allah.
And all of us were like,
what?
And then it's almost,
if you go to martial arts,
you look at like the whole history of martial arts and then you hit 1993 and it
goes like this.
Yeah.
It's like would be the craziest rise in the stock market.
You could ever say you'd have to investigate.
You have to be like,
what the fuck happened here?
Such an explosion.
It was UFC to u of C one.
No one really watched.
They didn't have any B roll.
I remember seeing a preview for it and I would watch all boxing events no matter
what.
It's a boxing fanatic.
I didn't miss any of those big fights ever.
Even the small Tuesday night fights,
I,
I recorded that on my VCR.
Always taped boxing events.
Never missed him,
but I didn't,
I didn't watch that.
I go,
you know what?
I thought it looks like it might be fake.
I thought maybe like a fight zone.
Remember fights are a little WWE,
but try to make it look,
uh,
you know,
more martial arts oriented.
But so I didn't watch it and then you end up,
you know,
you end up hearing shit that that was real.
And I'll never forget,
my roommate came home from Guitar Center and he said,
man,
that you have seat thing that UFC challenge.
That shit's for real man.
I don't really,
and I was doing karate at the time and I go,
was there a karate guy on there and goes yeah,
but he got beat by some,
I think he was Iranian man.
He was just choking everybody out.
He would just go,
he was choking everybody out.
What do you mean you would just grab the door?
Cause Dude,
yeah,
he would just grab the fucking throat,
some Iranian guy and he would choke.
He choked everybody out.
That's what the guy told me,
a guitar center.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
karate too.
I'm like fuck,
maybe I'm doing the wrong style.
And then the UFC,
UFC two came out in,
I remember I told my same roommate,
he was staying home,
it was on the weekend and I was going out on the town and I remember calling
them and say,
hey dude,
that UFC too,
that you have c challenge thing is on tape it because he was going to stay home
with his girlfriend.
He taped it.
I got home,
watched that motherfucker on tape.
I,
I couldn't stand hoists Gracie that first,
uh,
first half of the show,
I just wanted him to lose so bad when he fought MMA Gnocchi,
itchy horror.
There was a karate guy to me that was my hero.
I mean,
I was doing karate for six months,
man.
You know what I mean?
I was all about karate.
I didn't want hoist to beat him,
but then Ho,
but by the time we got to the finals,
I was a gigantic hoist fan.
I go,
you know what,
I got to learn this Jujitsu and I just quit karate and,
and um,
found,
uh,
the Machados in the valley.
It is really crazy when you think about what would have happened if that didn't
take place.
Like what would have happened if Horian never put together the,
the first ultimate fighter.
It was partly his idea and arc.
Davies.
Yeah.
What of what would happen if that didn't happen?
Where would martial arts be?
Would it be inevitable with somebody figured out with Japan and figured it out?
We would have figured it out eventually because maybe uh,
yeah,
cause the Jujitsu would eventually grew out of Brazil.
There's no way he could've stopped the looked the way it grew.
Yeah.
And that was a huge explosion,
but it have got out eventually,
but with maybe I'm for sure not with the same impact.
Yeah,
but see like forever wrestlers were like,
when you think about MMA right now,
wrestling's a giant scale,
right?
A Mark Coleman type wrestler.
Big powerful west.
We could take you down and beat you up from the top.
That's a giant.
That was always the case.
But we didn't think of that.
Like when you thought of like boxing versus wrestling or karate versus raffling.
Nobody thought,
look,
wrestlers have a giant advantage.
Nobody thought that you would think all the karate guy probably fuck him up.
Catch what a karate Chop Nisha on the way in or something like that.
I wrestled and I never thought wrestling was a martial art at all.
To me it was one on one football.
I had never looked at it but,
and I would use it to cheat and fights because I'd get in a fight in high
school,
I would just,
I would double leg them dude and just fucking get side,
twist your side control and punch him in the stomach.
And Tim.
Yeah,
but I,
you know,
I think that that was cheating,
but I didn't care.
It's,
I mean it is not a martial art in that it has finishing holds of its own because
most of it is just taking people down and holding them down and getting back up.
But if you can master that,
that is like one of the most important aspects of martial arts.
I mean,
and we never thought about it that way.
It took forever.
It's almost like it took the UFC to show that yeah.
Took the UFC to show that over and over again.
And I really worry or wonder rather what would have happened if the UFC in 93
had never been invented because of if there was never any kind of a tournament
like that to throw all these fighters together in a real organized way.
And he got real top level guys from each discipline eventually making their way
into the UFC.
What the fuck man?
A martial arts would be still back in the 1980s.
Yeah,
we'd have some idea of what worked and some idea would what,
you know,
don't,
don't try this,
but like we get down there,
we're doing Pancrase right.
Did they start doing pancreas?
I think they were doing it,
uh,
you know,
early nineties.
So it's a box.
Rutan Frank Shamrock,
Ken shamrock days,
Matt Hume's in it back then.
What years were those?
That's hard.
When was paying Crace one first aired on the 93 founding.
What month does it say?
93.
Damn.
Cause that was the first UFC two November of 93 was the first year I've seen.
So it all basically happened around the same time.
I mean is it possible that in November of 93 they see the UFC and then
immediately Pancrase starts like a few weeks later and it's still 93 that was
established on May 16th,
1993 and their first event was promoted,
uh,
September 21st so establishing that morning and then in September.
And what was the UFC in 93 November,
November crazy.
So right before the UFC.
So neither one of them had been on air when they both started or they're both
putting it together.
It was a maybe Elekta idea was in the air,
maybe was in the air pro to believe in that.
The idea is to just out there in the air that is pretty crazy.
But the fighters and Pancrase,
they
didn't have the Jujitsu that the Brazilians had.
No,
there's a big difference.
There's a lot of light lofts going on back then.
Remember it.
Is that Ken shamrocks influence or was that a,
there's a lot of Japan,
Japan,
like catch wrestling influence,
right.
Look from Karl gotch and yeah,
Jay Japan's always been into the leg locks.
Sissy Robinson.
Yeah.
They've always been like,
like the soccer style that's very cash oriented,
right?
Yes.
For those who don't know what we're talking about,
cash catch as catch can,
but make no mistake about it.
Did the ground fighting was just on another level.
You could say whatever the hell you want,
but when you watch,
AH,
Alan goes fight in Pancrase against
frank shamrock man,
do you see the difference in Jujitsu?
Back then there was a big,
big difference.
Alan goes was all over frank shamrock.
Frank shamrock is a bad motherfucker.
You know what I mean?
Only you know,
he'd only been training for a cop.
Yeah.
He,
yeah,
he just crazy.
Yeah.
He was fighting against guys like boss route and when he had been training for
like a couple of years.
Yeah.
I remember how Jack,
they were like,
Jesus,
anytime I'm wearing speedos,
anytime of Brazilian would,
uh,
would go against your,
your average pancreas guy.
There's a clear difference in the ground fighting current year difference and,
uh,
three pancreas offense before that first UFC Rolo all four events.
Oh yeah.
And what would you say in all,
all of them.
Interesting.
Yeah.
So look at that.
Bam.
It says that,
that the pancreas then came out of a wrestling organization in Japan where they
had like,
they were having problems with predetermined outcomes.
We started this.
Oh,
so you to have actual fights.
Yeah.
Funai interesting.
And then you look at Hixson versus Funai Colosseum.
Fucking difference in grappling.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
That's big as it gets.
So you could see that.
So what the UFC did that pank grace didn't do,
uh,
and mainly because nobody in the western hemisphere even knew what the fuck it
was.
It was a Japanese thing.
So it's going to be hard to change the world when you're,
you know,
only televised in Japan.
And back then,
you know,
you gotta get like someone,
someone had a mail,
you a VHS tape,
you know what I mean?
You had to go to weird Japanese stores and,
and,
and see that.
So,
but the UFC made it clear that the Brazilians were doing a form of ground
fighting.
It was beyond and more sophisticated what we're seeing in Japan or anywhere else
in the world.
You know,
nobody had half the shit they were doing.
No.
Sambo had a down Samo has some good shit and judo.
Yes.
Judo.
Um,
most if not all Brazilian jujitsu moves.
I mean,
have been done in judo and they're actually,
they came from Judah.
We know that.
The Japanese know that.
Uh,
but,
uh,
a lot of American judo guys don't,
they can't,
they can't seem to grasp back.
And they're like,
you know,
the Gracies ripped off Newaza ads.
It's all about nuance.
And we used to,
you know,
there was a,
a sect of judo where they did focus on the ground,
but,
and that's all true.
But the major difference is the Brazilians,
they wanted to do a style where there wasn't a time limit on the ground.
In Judo,
you could only find on the ground for,
I don't know,
30 seconds.
It's,
it's limited.
It's not that much time.
So when you don't have that much time,
there's a lot of shit.
You don't need to waste your time drilling because you're only going to be down
there for 30 seconds.
You need to focus on the moves that work in 30 seconds and that's it.
You don't have time to set shit up and be patient and relax.
You can't clench and catch your breath.
You got to,
it's got to,
you got to go into it.
So with the Brazilians did is just allowed the fight to unfold on the ground
and,
and not have any standups and just let them fight on the ground.
And when that happens,
there's a lot,
there's so much more you can do when there's no time limit on the ground.
Not like no timeline.
I mean,
you know,
they're not going to without standups where you could just,
most of the matches,
Tate is,
takes place on the ground.
The game just evolves so quickly and so rapidly and,
and uh,
that you can't compare like eat Japanese guys come down to Brazil.
They did been doing judo their whole life and they get smoked by Brazilians.
That always happens in the world championships.
The Brazilians are just on the ground all day,
you know,
and the guys that do judo there on the ground a little bit,
they're never going to be able to compete in a sport where there's no standups.
You know,
so to say that,
uh,
Brazilian Jujitsu is just judo.
It's,
that's,
um,
you got to think about it.
You've got to really break it down.
Cause it's,
yeah,
it still is.
It's silly.
There's so many silly connections to people have to arts,
you know,
I mean there's,
there's people that legitimately think that white people shouldn't be able to
teach karate because it's cultural appropriation because it's a Japanese art.
There's people that think that stupid,
you know,
there's,
I think all of it's martial arts now.
I mean,
I think the roots and the bases are very important to recognize that,
you know,
hey,
Brazil did do a crazy thing with Jujitsu.
Hey,
uh,
the ties did do a crazy thing with leg kicks and elbows,
knees.
There's really some,
some people that have contributed to martial arts and it's really insane way.
And the people that highlight those disciplines like the elite of the elites,
like the book house and the Sand Shies and the Marcello Garcias and the jock
arrays,
like all these people that highlighted on,
in each art,
they're all like super,
super important.
But overall it all comes into one thing.
And that's,
that's martial arts.
I think martial arts,
it's really,
um,
at this point it's really,
I mean ultimately it's,
it's one thing now ultimately,
ultimately,
like when you,
when you think about UFC,
when you think about just Bruce Lee movies,
what is it like fight how,
what's the best way to fight?
It's all together now.
It's all combined because the best way is not just wrestling,
it's wrestling with ferocious striking.
It's wrestling with leg kick defense,
it's wrestling with submission holds.
It's all these different things.
You have to have all these things.
You can't just be one thing anymore.
It's interesting to be from one discipline,
but it's like what if a kid is coming up right now and he's like your son's and
he starts
to learn martial arts techniques.
I think by the time he gets to be our age,
it's just going to be martial arts.
We were just going to be taking martial arts.
I don't think there's going to be as many specialists in the future.
And I think that's probably a shame.
Like,
but no,
who's gonna want from a guy who did taekwondo his whole life?
Who's going to want to do that now?
Yeah.
But when you're talking about Jujitsu,
um,
most people that do Jujitsu,
are not doing it,
uh,
or they don't stay in it for the long haul and make it a lifestyle for the self
defense aspects.
They don't know.
They go in there cause they're playing a video game and they're staying in shape
right there playing a game of death,
virtual reality video game,
trying to get taps.
Try not to get a tap that much,
you know.
So do most of the guys in,
in,
you know that most of my students,
they're just like,
you know,
super nice sweetheart computer geeks,
just,
just the nicest guys.
They're not in there,
in there just to play.
Yeah.
Well there's a big difference between,
um,
we've talked about this before,
but the big difference between guys who trained together,
which are Jyutsu first guys train together with like kickboxing as the
kickboxing people,
they fucking hurt each other all the time.
Like bad.
Like they're beating each other up,
they're kicking each other,
punching each other and shit.
Jujitsu guys tap each other out and they're like,
oh,
I'm gonna get you back bitch.
And it's,
but it's okay.
Everybody's okay.
And that's the beauty of it.
We get to the,
the,
the reason why Jujitsu is,
uh,
it's,
I mean opening up a Jujitsu school like in,
in,
in society today is like one of the safest bets out there ever.
I,
it gets so addicting.
You can't download Jujitsu,
you can't pirate Jujitsu.
You know you are sparring rounds,
you know,
you,
you can't,
you have to go to a place and you have to go to a place where there's a bunch of
different and the more people there are,
the better.
The more variety of roles you can get.
Cause you don't want to just roll with the same guy all the time.
You want to mix it up,
mix your style with that guy style.
Go with the new guy who doesn't know your secret moves.
And he'd go on and you're like going with new dudes where you're,
your setups work because the guys that you've been rolling with for awhile,
they smell out all your setups.
Now you've got to come up with new setups and then you've got to figure out a
different way around this problem.
It's just,
um,
it's just too much fun,
man.
It's,
it's so addicting and it has nothing to do with not,
I wouldn't say nothing,
but,
uh,
you know,
you do enjoy,
um,
the,
the self defense aspects,
like if anything went down,
it makes you feel better in certain situations.
Like you're not
as worried about things as you might be if you didn't know if he didn't know
martial arts.
You know,
the one thing that,
uh,
I'm going to start doing once I'm totally healed again,
I'm going to start kickboxing.
Yeah.
Cause I just see too many Instagram videos of dudes getting fucking lit up.
I'm like,
you know what,
it's a good idea once a week,
you know,
and I'm not going to make
a big deal out of it.
Maybe once a week tops once a week just to go in there and just sit up.
Video put up on Instagram today from Draka.
It's like a,
I think it's Draka underscored junior is the Instagram account.
It's a crazy Russian account and it's a two on one Russian fighting a giant dude
and two like normal size guys.
Yeah,
look at this.
Give you some volume.
JV.
This is crazy.
Both of these guys do.
They do about one 60 and the other guy looks like he's about 300 fucking pounds.
Okay.
This
guy's ragdoll on these dudes that was knees.
Fuck this guy's giant,
man.
He's so much bigger than these two dudes.
Oh,
look at this.
He's a beast.
Holy Shit.
You have to do cardio two for a giant fucking dude.
This is the white Kimbo.
Yeah,
look,
he's a good leg kick checking.
He's got technique.
He's not just a giant dude.
They're not faking it,
right?
Oh Man.
They're beating the fuck out of each other.
He's,
he's hitting his fucking guy hard.
Oh,
we'll kick.
This is crazy.
I mean,
this is not a smart thing for the little dudes because the problem is they don't
have the horsepower.
They're not going to be able to take them out any videos on Instagram or due to
get lit up.
You got to have,
you've got to have the ability to knock somebody out if you had to and not do
Jiu Jitsu.
There's many situations where in a real life altercation,
getting on the ground is not the best idea.
And uh,
being able to light someone up or like three dudes,
no way.
You're going to be three dudes with Jujitsu,
you know,
and it happens,
you see on videos is like a myth.
It's like a mythical thing.
You can't beat multiple attackers.
Yes.
You fucking can like as you could with their striking,
if there was three dudes and then we're starting shit and you're like,
okay,
I'm gonna knock this motherfucker out first.
And then hopefully one dude,
we'll start running and then I'll fucking clean up the second guy,
you know,
or whatever.
But to have your level of striking is important.
It's important.
You know,
it's important.
It's important.
If you think that some of might be hitting you,
like if you think some of this mother fucker looks like he's going to swing on
me,
like I've got a feeling like he's going to swing on me.
Yeah.
There's,
there's that,
that,
that moment when you're in a heightened sense of danger.
If you don't understand space,
like that's a real big thing.
One of the things about sparring that's really important is that you,
you know when you're safe and when you're not safe and you like,
a lot of people don't know,
they don't know when they can hit someone,
when someone can hit them.
And if someone thinks,
if you think someone's going to hit you and you can't get some space between
the,
you have to be ready and you have to understand like you have to have someone
have swung on you before.
So as you're seeing shit coming,
you gotta be able to,
oh his back legs gone.
Okay.
I see.
Is Weight dip into the right hands coming in?
You know like there's a,
there's a,
you have to know certain,
otherwise
you lock up.
That's the scariest thing you ever seen a fight is dudes like things start
swinging and they just lock up cause they don't know what,
they don't know where it's coming from.
They don't know what's happening.
That's the most dangerous.
It's almost more important for defense than it is for anything because half the
time,
if you were ever in a fight with someone and they start just swinging at you,
if you have good defense,
you just stand there with your hands up and you wait.
You just wait,
let him swing,
keep moving.
You wait.
How long are you gonna be able to do this?
Well,
you got 30 seconds in you.
He just wait.
He just wait and then all of sudden you see a little of this and you're like,
oh,
now you're tired.
You don't really know how to fight.
He just wanted to hit me when now we're going to fight and now you're tired.
Someone didn't do as sprints.
Well,
dot.
Just that you don't know what to do.
You,
you lock up and you're like,
eh.
People think that they can do that to people.
People that don't know how to fight,
blow their load.
They just blow their wad.
If you ever,
like if a guy like Joe Schilling is in a street fight,
there would be like the most terrifying thing in the world.
Like if you don't know and you fuck up.
And he got in some crazy street fight after one of his kickboxing fights
recently and some other country,
but a guy like that,
first of all,
he can fuck you up before you can fuck him up.
But second of all,
if he decides to just take his time with you,
well,
you're going to get into this place of doom,
this place of doom where you're exhausted and you've been trying to hurt him.
So he has all everything within his right to crush you and you know that and now
you're tired.
Yeah.
But uh,
oh,
well the one thing that you notice in all of these fight videos and scuffles on
Instagram is that,
uh,
a lot of times it just seems like you got,
you got timed up to throw a couple punches and you ain't got to get the fuck
out.
Especially when it's multiple attackers.
Yeah.
You got to figure out which dude you're going to hit first.
There's going to be another one and usually that third guy runs it looks like.
He's like,
Oh shit,
he's out.
But if he stays down you one on one now you just knocked two dudes out.
Now it's one on one and if you got Joe Schilling type skills,
boom,
that's where it all comes in right there.
But it's almost better to just have wrestling and boxing in a street fight.
You don't really want to catch some.
Bruce Lee was preaching after all the shit after everything.
He all the Kung Fu he grew up with,
he got to the states and he realized,
Holy Shit,
this wing Chung isn't working on this tall white boys.
So he learned really quick a fight in a street closed quarters.
I mean maybe you be able to throw a kick through and he said in 1959 he said a
dude has been wrestling and boxing for one year can beat a lifelong martial
artists.
It's true.
Yeah,
it's true in a lot of ways.
If a guy doesn't know,
take down defense and the guy doesn't know how to actually box.
Dude.
I remember when I first started doing first started learning boxing and
kickboxing from all my years of doing taekwondo
and I threw punches and taekwondo,
but I had a crazy,
distorted perception of my ability with my hands.
Like I thought it'd be able to,
I was like,
I know how to strike that.
He doesn't know how to strike.
I just knew how to do taekwondo.
I was good at that.
And then when I started kickboxing,
dude,
I was getting lit up.
Especially when you're in it.
Rain can't go anywhere.
You trapped in this ring.
Does taekwondo have a reverse punch?
Yeah,
it's got reverse punch.
Scott,
you know,
it's got all these,
he's got a hand techniques,
but when you fight and tournament's,
everything is below the neck for punches.
So everything is below here.
It's just the body for punches and you can kick to the head and he kicked to the
body.
You can't kick to the legs.
So all it does is make you really good at kicking.
That's what it really does.
But the,
the,
the distance is all fucked up.
And then I realized that like once I started doing kickbox,
all my distance is so fucked up because when I think I'm safe,
I'm good still get punched in the face.
And if the crowd may,
they get punched in the face and I can't kick him,
like my distance is all messed up and then it's also way easier to punch me than
I thought it was.
So I had to learn and and,
and in learning it was fucking super humbling man.
Super humbling because I went from being someone who I considered myself like an
elite striker.
Like I was on a national level for taekwondo.
I,
I fought in a lot of national tournament's I could,
I fought like a bunch of guys were really good and I hung in there with them.
I thought it was really good.
Just regular kickboxers Pete and the fuck out of me just beating my ass dude.
Just getting me in the corner,
Jabbing me broken off the jab right hand.
I'm like,
you're calling.
Oh No,
this is terrible,
isn't it?
Isn't it weird for sure.
Taekwondo has got the best,
uh,
spinning kicks in.
All that shit.
Yeah.
It's got some really good kicks.
The sidekick is the best kick for sure.
Best.
Uh,
the best version of the side kicks the taekwondo sign that the heads of the
Taekwondo Association,
whatever the,
whatever it's called,
they,
they can't add.
They can't admit that their hands suck.
You know what I mean?
They can't admit it.
You would think that the heads would say,
you know what,
Shit maybe we should do.
Maybe we should add western boxing to this shit.
You know what I mean of them do.
I'm sure some of them do.
So I'm heads dumped it.
Like you would think it's so traditional,
like they won't change it.
It's cars to clear.
It's crystal clear that the best hands are Western boxing hands.
It's crystal clear.
The world knows this.
But at the top,
like you don't like even in the karate associations or come through associations
bay,
they won't alter the style.
Right,
right.
Well,
you know,
one thing that is interesting is karate at least emphasizes the idea of punching
things without gloves on because there is a difference.
There's a pretty big difference to punching things with gloves on without gloves
on.
And one of the things that karate figured out a long time ago,
so you've got to condition your knuckles,
condition your hands and condition your knuckles.
They never had that even,
I mean I guess maybe some people had it in taekwondo,
but it was never anything in my organization where they have like a mock Hawara,
which is like a book.
If you don't know what we're talking about.
There's a board with rope wrapped around its hard rope and they just fucking
smacked,
just punched that rope until their knuckles became like my friend John Lee who I
told you about,
he's the guy that I saw kicked the bag for the first time and Ben didn't have
national champion.
He was a monster.
He had one hand where he only had one knuckle is his first two knuckles were
just one.
It was one giant.
Not,
it wasn't,
it wasn't like my hand looks like with two distinct knuckles.
It was just a boulder over there all from punching bricks who just break bricks
with his knuckles and he would pray work.
So that shit works.
Oh yeah.
Mad Mad arthritis when he get older.
Oh really?
Shit.
So not good to just beat on a joint until a callous and forget that this is what
I heard.
Maybe that's a,
maybe that's a fake rumor too,
but a lot of those guys that uh,
that did that,
they would practice on Maca wars and on bricks and just constantly be punching
bricks.
And so John had hands where he could lick legitimately punched someone very hard
and not worry about it with bare knuckle.
Whereas a lot of people in your hand,
your hand is way we think about what your hand is like.
Move your hand around like this.
Think about all these little parts.
This is the worst thing you want to hit somebody with.
That's why this elbows are so much better.
Elbows are so much better.
Your palms even better.
Yeah.
This is crazy.
This thing articulate and it moved.
This is for piano.
It's not for Hulk Smash.
Look at this.
Oh Shit.
Thoughts it money wise that a guy's arthritis from using the [inaudible].
There was a styles knuckles.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
Nice.
There was a style that did a address weaknesses in a bunch of styles and just do
you remember?
Um,
and then I forget who formed it,
but he formed a style that had the best of what he thought of like five systems
caught.
You Kimbo remember that cod?
You Kimbo who packed to get karate?
A Jew maybe Jujitsu or judo cause you can't add and Kempo karate and Bart Vale
and Bo.
No.
And a bowl for boxing,
Silva's boxing,
karate,
judo and Kempo karate.
Do you remember Bart Vale?
Yeah.
Dude Barksdale was another guy who was like a pioneer of MMA that people seem to
have forgot about Kaci Kimbo I can't believe I just remembered him.
Oh look at that was a little bit of a wing.
Chung,
a little bit of sidekick in
Google.
Bart Vail.
He was one of the early guys.
Man,
I fucking completely forgot about him.
He was a big giant dude too.
He's a shoot fighter.
Yeah,
he fought.
That's right.
He fought fucking Cam shamrock in pancreas.
Look at this.
Yeah.
And this is before the UFC too.
These guys used to,
okay.
They,
they had the open slap was interesting too.
Right?
There weren't a lot of punch each other.
They,
but they were allowed to open slap.
Like how weird is that?
So strange watching these old,
old fights.
US Big fucking Bart veil is compared to Ken Shamrock,
who's a big fucking dude,
man.
He always had American flag shorts on.
Right.
The one thing we failed to mention that,
that we should bring up is whether or not Horian Gracie or art Davey or
influenced by pancreas or not.
Like what came out first.
So a few months in Brazil,
they were doing that shit since like the 20s and thirties and forties yeah.
Right.
So really it probably all started in Brazil.
If you break it down like that,
I mean hell y'all Gracie was fighting what in the forties or the 50s or
something.
Yeah.
You know,
Carlson Gracie took over like in the 60s it was huge in Brazil.
So not only did Brazil,
it not only is Brazil responsible for the level of grappling in the world today,
it's,
it's for sure the Brazilians got to have all the credit for that for sure.
Come on now.
Yeah,
I mean when,
so also MMA,
they were doing valley today.
Only $2 old school.
They were the Brazilians for some reason.
I don't know what it,
what it was,
but they figured out a lot of good shit.
Right.
Then Hixon Gracie match news 18 against Zulu,
the figured out [inaudible] he are you kidding me?
You've got an Uber Tuba right there on Ventura.
You ever go there?
No.
That's the kind of cause all these little pussy ass little juice shops try to
have [inaudible] they don't do it right.
The,
the way Uber Tuba does it is exactly the way you get it in Brazil.
So God damn,
what is this 1920s fighting sideshows called Valley Tudo became popular in
Brazilian circus is during the 1920s Jesus Christ.
So they were doing this before they found Jujitsu.
And Jujitsu.
They just figured it like the them see the,
the last piece of the puzzle.
They were already doing it before 1920.
It says Kelly.
Oh,
started her.
I think Heleo is doing Jujitsu and the 20,
13,
14 or something.
When did my eight to come to Brazil?
That's a good question.
When did,
I thought that was in the fourth year.
Did Heleo Gracie because Carlos Gracie learned first.
What year did Carlos Gracie first learn Jujitsu?
Count my Ada.
Right.
It was count my eight.
Uh,
when did he first meet Carlos Gracie?
It's amazing,
man.
Again,
think about the billions of people on the planet.
These two people don't meet.
If one guy doesn't teach another guy judo,
the whole world's different.
Yeah.
Fucking crazy.
Really crazy.
And then what country did you go to?
You know,
did he go to Norway or did he go to Germany?
Did he go?
No,
no,
you went to this place where they're already doing this.
He comes down to teachers of at a place where they're already
getting wild or they're already having these wild ass fights and he figures out
how to get it to the craziest family or the best way possible.
You see the word creamy
sort of in 1917
I do.
Yes.
So maybe they learn Jujitsu and they remain start having fights.
Exactly.
Maybe Valerie Trudeau who invented valley too though.
Was it the Gracies?
How crazy is that?
Who first started doing Valley Tuto in Brazil?
That's what,
that's what I wanted.
Been influenced by the initial learning of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu from three years
ago.
Or maybe it's just a bunch of dudes who were terrible at Jujitsu.
Just like in Japan.
Well,
when I came into the UFC was 97 so it was basically the same amount of time
afterwards.
Right.
So think about if like Jujitsu is introduced to Brazil three years before they
start doing these valley to dope things.
When I first got into the UFC,
it was 97 and you and I went to one in 97 member.
Yup.
And those days it was,
everything was like,
it was like,
it had to be probably how,
like how they were on a larger scale because it was on cable,
but how they were looking at it like,
oh,
here's this new thing.
Everybody's figured out this new thing.
This is the new thing.
Oh,
can we try this new thing?
We're going to have these fights.
I'm gonna put these fights together.
Real similar timeline.
But the Brazilians,
we're,
how many years earlier?
1920,
70,
70 years earlier.
It was anybody doing that before the 1920 to do that.
It's really crazy.
Who really invented valid know?
Oh,
maybe it was like,
uh,
maybe,
you know what?
Maybe a them catch wrestling.
Um,
a no holds bar fights that they would do an insert kisses.
There was a little something with it.
Yeah.
Maybe that,
I think that was in the 18 hundreds.
Yeah.
Set A and M my adas Wikipedia that at nine 18 to 79,
Ulysses s grant,
former president at the time,
visited Japan and while in Tokyo attended a Jujitsu presentation.
Whoa.
Interesting.
1879,
1879 but Japanese,
Japanese,
do you get these different than Brazilian Jujitsu?
Well,
didn't was it Teddy Roosevelt,
one of them way different.
Studied judo.
Some one of the,
one of the former presidents study judo today,
Abraham Lincoln before he was president,
used to travel around and re challenge the rest of us.
Yeah.
He's a big old tall dude.
See I think there's a lot of those guys that a would do that just for money.
They would travel around and then there was people that would take on all comers
and you know,
local towns.
It was a way to make money.
Yeah.
But the rules matter,
like if you're doing challenge matches,
uh,
cause in catch wrestling in the sport,
you're not allowed to put someone in full guard.
I don't think.
I don't know about God is like in Russell the rules in wrestling,
wrestling,
then just regular wrestling.
You can't put anybody in your garden and work your guard and catch wrestling.
Similar catch wrestling.
You can win by pin too.
Right?
Is that think so.
It's,
it's um,
that's like what?
It's,
it's a wrestling based art,
but you could also get a guy and Kamora yes.
Or an Americana.
Yeah,
you choke them.
It truly is I think so a submission,
wrestling with the problem and the big problem with catch wrestling and has a
lot of wonderful things for sure.
Um,
a lot like,
you know,
the Camorra,
there's a lot of great shit and catch wrestling,
but the fact that,
uh,
you can't put you can't work from your full guard,
means that not only does the system have no guard work really or,
or super limited guard work,
like someone's going to send me a picture of look a picture of some old catch
wrestler in the guard or something.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
I,
I get it.
It existed.
But I'm talking about,
um,
a sport where you're allowed to work from the guard with without being stood up
or without being penalized.
You know what I mean?
Y'alls didn't have that.
So what,
what means?
What that means is the guard passing was nonexistent as well.
If you don't want,
if you're not allowed to play guard,
why would you bother learning and drilling all these different paths?
Combos.
It's a lot of time.
So that's,
that's what the kid catch wrestling was missing was the guard and the guard
passing.
But they had all the submissions and it's a beautiful thing,
but it was like that in Japan in a lot of ways too that when you watch old Penn,
no one's working from the guard.
There's no tech,
there's no technical half guard stuff.
There's,
it's just wide open basic movements,
um,
off your back.
And that's one of the,
that's the biggest thing that the Brazilians brought to the game is guard
passing.
Um,
which means on the flip side,
you've got to have,
you know,
super hard guard to pass,
and that changes everything.
I changed everything and,
and uh,
and trying to figure out a way to do real fights,
you know,
that's why they had a fake,
a lot of fights because there was so much missing.
The fights would,
you know,
when you put two white belts together on the ground,
there's not going to be a submission going on.
It's going to be a,
it's not going to be entertaining to watch two people on the ground in a
position like the guard or whatever,
where you just don't spend a lot of time and it gets really boring.
So that's why you'd have to fake it.
You're like,
you know what,
if we're going to allow him by fake it like pro wrestling,
like pro wrestling,
the origins of pro wrestling.
I mean if you look,
think about pro wrestling,
pro wrestling is just a fake UFC cause they're on the ground.
They do a,
um,
they,
you know,
they do leg locks and shit and they do,
they'll do Google.
Black does now,
but grave digging all over the fucking the undertaker.
Yeah.
Only because they would have did it before if they would've known what was
possible.
They just didn't spend enough time on the ground without standups and without
penalties to figure out there's so much you could do on the ground.
And that's,
that's what changed everything.
That's what made it so that you don't have to fake fights anymore.
Although there are fake fights,
you know,
especially in your path.
I think that's why they started faking fights.
I think they just wanted to make it more entertaining and they want to be able
to do it every night.
Well,
yes,
that's I saw on the road.
No,
no,
that's what I'm saying.
They want to make it more entertaining if it,
if it's real,
it's not entertaining because you have two dudes.
You want to be able to do it every night.
You want.
You want to be able to travel on the road.
I know channel 10 I don't know their schedule.
I don't know exactly how to grew up.
Yeah.
Maybe they went out once every six months.
Maybe they went out every once a month.
I'm not too sure of the frequency of their fights,
but 100% you go,
you take a time machine back to 1860 and you go to a carnival and you watch this
dude,
that guy dude's grapple.
You're not going to see a high tech guard work.
You know what I mean?
You're not going to see high tech guard passing,
you're just not going to see it exist.
It exist in judo,
but not that much because yeah,
unless you're doing new Waza Newaza was a judo style that spent more time on the
ground,
but still they didn't make an impact.
Like,
like,
uh,
the Gracies did well.
When you watch someone who's a really good guard expert on their back and you
know,
you watched someone trapped in that Web,
you know,
it's,
it's really,
it's very interesting now you don't have to fake exist before the UFC that
thought that a guy on his back could be like super dangerous.
That was a totally new concept.
Yeah.
Dan Severn hoists grace.
That was the one you had a fight like that one exist.
I mean,
he was on his back and he had Dan Severn and his guard,
I don't know,
like 15 minutes or something like that.
It was a long time.
That was the longest match hoist had been in and he ended up triangling up.
You know,
you,
uh,
you know,
when you,
when the Arno standups a lot more patience is involved.
And,
um,
set ups and,
and there's so much more.
It's like a whole nother dimension opens up when there's no standups.
So this weekend is Darren till versus Wonderboy.
Excuse me versus Tyron Woodley.
Why don't I say versus Wonderboy?
We'll kind of flip was that,
and you know why?
Because it was reading a article of this really interesting article about
Wonderboy and his last three fights,
the two fights with Tyron Woodley that were super duper close.
And then one fight with Darren till that was also really close.
And they were talking about like how,
um,
if you looked at it on paper,
the people from outside,
I think there were,
there were saying that global scorecard,
I think that's how they're describing it,
meaning how people scored it,
like on average around the world.
Uh,
more people gave it to Wonderboy then gave it to Darren till.
And the same thing happened with,
um,
the Tyron Woodley fights.
I feel like the decisions were right in all those fights.
I feel like I'm in the woods.
He fights in particular Woodley hurt Wonderboy.
Wonderboy didn't really hurt with the,
I think that counts for more.
It just does Woodley.
Um,
Tyron Woodley had them out.
I mean he had,
I'm really hurt and Wonderboy never had Tyron in that kind of trouble in either
one of those fights.
So I would,
I would give that advantage clearly to tire and I would think that if he lost
that fight,
that would make it any sense.
Cause fights are supposed to be about who does the most damage.
Who of WHO's more effective.
I mean Wonderboy was effective for more time,
but that's just like movement and sticking and hitting him,
hitting him with small shots.
But Tyron put him on,
you know,
unconsciousness his door.
He was like right there.
It was very dangerous.
It was way different.
And plus you got the camp pals.
Yeah.
They said,
well I,
I'm,
I'm not sure I believe that.
I think,
you know,
if someone really wins a decision,
they really wanted decision,
but it's just what's most important is damage.
If you,
you guys are basically in a striking exchange.
We're not talking about like submission attempts versus striking exchanges.
Like which one's better?
He almost had him choked out with that triangle.
Well,
he almost had them knocked out with that left hook.
We're not talking about that because it was basically just a striking match and
in just as plain old striking match,
Willie was the one who landed the bigger shots.
In my mind.
We've got to figure out a way to quantify that.
It just doesn't make any sense where you could see a guy having a guy fucked up
and almost out to,
I think the same way about the Robert Whitaker Yoel Romero fight.
There's two rounds in that fi where Yoel Romero is land in bombs on Whitaker.
Whitaker is hurt bad.
How does he lose that fight?
I don't understand that.
It doesn't make sense to me.
Even if it makes sense in the current scoring system,
that scoring system is fucking flawed.
That shit doesn't make any sense.
Like a logically when you're looking at what is the,
what's the ultimate goal of fighting.
But if you look at those three fights,
just at least on paper wonder boys like right up there and Darren till with one
fight with cowboy one fight with him.
Those two fights were their most high profile fights of his career.
Boom already got a title shot.
It's really interesting.
That's how,
that's how talented Darren till is.
People are so interested in him.
17 to know,
25 years old,
they're like,
fuck,
give him a chance.
The real battle for this guy almost is not just a the fight,
which is going to be of course a battle,
but making 170 and how much longer does he do that?
He's,
I mean he fucking,
he's hurting to get down to one 70 apparently he was at one 82 yes,
he's giant dude.
Giant.
You see how much bigger he is in Woodley?
This is the video at the press conference.
When I stand next to each other and how tall is he till puts his hands over his
head.
I can't tell.
It says inches high.
He's gotta be six too.
But he said a big giant,
six to six foot even.
That's just six foot even 72 inches.
That's right.
It is.
He seems way taller than that.
Watch the go to the video of them.
Um,
that's crazy.
Why don't think he was six to anyway,
just still,
we're talking one 70 his clearly taller.
He's a big fucker too.
It's not just tall.
He's thick.
You know he's a,
he's a big fucking guy and he has a hard time making that weight.
Look how fucking big he is,
dude.
Seriously.
That looks like more than three inches.
Unless he's wearing some crazy cowboy boots.
I don't know,
but look,
it's going to be hard to do anything that Woodley man.
Very hard.
Well,
there's a bunch of things with wood and the first of all,
the fucking speed you're dealing with speed that you,
you probably haven't seen before.
Exactly.
And that his level of wrestling,
look at these two guys.
He doesn't want to to isn't,
there's no submitting till.
I mean,
he knows Jujitsu for sure.
He lived in Brazil for a few years.
He actually speaks,
speaks Portuguese.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
he got stabbed in London and then uh,
went to Brazil to fucking recoup and hi,
hang out and live there for awhile.
I don't know the full story of it,
but he speaks perfect Portuguese after one of his fights in Brazil,
he addressed the crowd and Portuguese or she crazy.
I haven't heard any trash talking from uh,
Connor as I have.
I have,
I missed it.
He's not doing any press.
He's not,
oh,
shit is not doing anything.
Figured it out.
You figured out the promotion on your dawn.
Here is,
what about a countdown shops?
I Bay,
I think he basically said,
listen man,
I'm going to fight and that's it.
That's what's going to happen October six.
I'm not doing like the promotion to think he's done,
man.
Now he's hit that play.
First of all,
he just won $100 million.
He probably thinks that you could suck all the decks.
I'm here right now.
If you want milk,
I want to fight.
That's what I want to do.
I don't want to do any of your bullshit.
I want to fight.
So on October 6th I'm going to show up and fight,
figured out all the rest.
October 5th I'll be there to make weight.
October six and his accent though,
I wish I could.
I'd have to listen to him a few more times.
If he dies,
he dies.
Then it says,
hold on,
go back down.
Right.
What are you doing?
If he dies,
he dies.
Then I'm paid twice.
It's got 1.3 million light.
What does that mean?
Yeah.
It's a lot of likes so much.
What does that mean right there?
Yeah.
He's trying to just stay relevant.
Let's try to put some words out there.
Look sexy.
It probably got someone to doing it for them.
Some a little assistant and you know,
he's probably concentrate on the fight and they said Conor is just good.
And he's like,
yeah,
it's fucking good.
Put it up.
I,
I'll tell you what man,
I can't fucking wait for that fight.
And you know,
you know if one of them drop out,
you know Tony Anderson?
Yeah.
Tony Ferguson.
Ready to go.
And he's on the card anyway.
And the undercard against Pedis.
Right.
So they would definitely do Ferguson and not Pettis.
Uh,
I think so.
I'm not sure.
I think,
did they offer Norma Madoff to pedis when all that shit was going down in New
York and Brooklyn?
I know the offered it to.
Um,
they were gonna have it.
[inaudible] got cut.
Right.
And they wouldn't,
they didn't let Paul Felder cause Paul Felder wasn't ranked high enough,
which is crazy.
They let ally acquainted do it,
but it was,
I think they offered his report was Pettis and fell to,
were both denied.
Mm.
Interesting medicine,
Felder,
bolts and nuts.
Well,
um,
you know,
has just [inaudible]
by triangle.
He looked good.
He looked like he's back.
That I'm,
I don't,
I selfishly hope that uh,
no one drops out because first of all I want to see that fight.
But two,
I really want to see Tony versus pedis.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a really interesting fight,
man.
Yeah,
Tony's looking good man.
I bet he is looking good.
It's amazing how quick he came back from that surgery.
It's amazing,
man.
It's amazing.
He's looking really good.
He's breakdancing and wants to break dance when he's guy just blew his knee
ligaments off his bones,
quit drinking,
no more drink and he's,
it's cleanest.
Fuck has diets.
He looks great right now.
Cause look squad.
Yeah,
he's in,
he's in tremendous shape.
How much was he drinking them for the best shape of his life?
Uh,
you know,
a couple of beers here and there,
you know what I mean?
Uh,
no big deal.
But he's um,
but he said,
fuck none of that.
No.
Oh Dude,
that injury just changed everything for him.
That injuries.
Like it just made them reevaluate his life and now he's coming back stronger
than ever,
man.
Well,
when something like that happens,
you realize like,
Whoa,
one of these,
that's really,
this catastrophic could be the end of my career.
Yeah.
It's possible.
And it's so possible that Connor or Khabib could drop out at soap possible.
So possible.
That's the backup plan.
Pedis and Tony is the backup plan.
But what are we at now?
We're still a month away.
Today's the sixth.
We have a whole month.
Yup.
Dude,
the world could fall apart in a month and a month.
Yeah.
And it,
that weekend is going to be fucking insane cause that's,
that's in Vegas on that,
on that Saturday,
the Friday before his quintet three.
That's going to be insane.
What's that?
If he seen quintet yet?
The team Jujitsu only Jujitsu.
What?
Soccer Robichaud.
Oh my God.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
I'm confused.
I thought you meant team like four guys against four guys attacking each other
all at once.
No,
no,
no.
I was watching that video.
The Russian guy.
It's still in my head and I nine nine a quintet.
Sakharova shell.
I did,
I saw the Bogie choked out soccer,
rob.
I was like,
the craziest Shit I've ever seen.
Craziest experience of ever been in my life is as far as Jujitsu goes.
It's so different now.
I've never done this teen Jujitsu.
It's fucking insane.
It was so many ups and downs in saying why was Geo grappled against the guy that
was so big?
Well this is the way they do it.
Okay,
so there's four teams.
It's a,
it's a four man bracket and you know,
the winner of these two teams fights the winner,
these two teams,
and then they have their,
you're in the finals,
so it's five on five,
950 pound weight limit.
So you get the whole stack for the whole five.
Oh,
you get to divvy it up,
however you want humans to monsters series two matches.
But then you've got to have like little,
little guys here.
So,
um,
and when ends up happening,
we had to,
we had Adam sack Knauf and Amea alarm are two giant guys that are like both,
like two 20.
And then,
uh,
we had geo,
PJ and Boogie,
um,
made up the rest of the team.
So we had two guys,
a couple medium guys.
And then Gio is a small guy.
Geosys the smallest guy,
but he's like Ge.
It was like one 41 45.
He does when he fights one 35.
Right?
He walks around like one 40,
one 40.
So you,
every team has to submit the order.
They want their fighters to go,
but without knowing your opponent order.
So you,
you just line them up however you want and then boom,
they just banned this is the matchup,
like,
oh shit.
You know,
um,
you could have giants against little dudes.
You know,
it's all mixed up.
You just ban.
Does anybody have to agree?
Nope.
So who gets to put the guy out first?
Like when you're making the decisions now this is what happens.
You have to,
every team has to submit the order that they want their,
their fighters to go out.
So I had no,
it's random.
So I say,
Eddie,
you go out first.
Jamie goes out second riding down,
submit it,
and they got sick and they just put them together.
That's ridiculous.
You don't know how your,
your,
your opponents,
the other team's going to line them up.
So boom,
when they line up,
when they,
you see how it lined up,
you're like,
oh shit.
So the craziest thing was we,
you know,
we had to beat,
the first team we win against was,
um,
issues team each.
She is the biggest,
best built Japanese of all time of all times,
like 250 pound Japanese,
like six foot three,
six foot four built.
Like Ray Lewis is easy to gold medalist.
Gold medalist in judo.
Yeah,
he's in dude.
He's so cool too.
The Guy,
he's awesome.
He's a,
he's as English is pretty good and I'm just fight MMA a little bit.
Yeah.
In Japan.
The dude is,
I've never seen a Japanese built like this motherfucker.
I've never,
he's like Brock fucking lesson,
our shit.
You know what I mean?
It's insane.
He's,
he's a,
he's a very intimidating and giant.
So that was the first time we were gone again.
So I go fuck.
We were like Holy Shit.
And plus that Xiao assists,
which is a big ass Brazilian.
He's like 210 pounds.
One of the best Brazilian Jujitsu guys out then.
He's not the Japanese team.
He's on issues team.
So it's [inaudible] big high level world champion,
Abu Dhabi champion.
He went to Abu Dhabi once to God and he,
she and then they had three other guys,
right.
So we had to go against them first.
But,
but the first two teams that went while we're in the locker room,
soccer Robin's team when against Tiger Muay Thai team,
right.
It was a steward Cooper's team.
So to each she up there,
Jesus Christ,
he's jacked like the size of him mad.
He's so fucking big.
He's huge in person.
He's huge.
I'm sure man.
It's incredible.
But rampage right?
Was that in Strikeforce?
Bella tour?
He fought rampage and Bella tour.
So we're in the back.
I wish I would have videotape their shit.
One in the back locker room.
It's a nice arena and everything.
So it's like,
we're like at a,
like a basketball arena.
We're in the,
in the back watching the first two guys go and soccer.
Rob had this giant black guy on his team.
His name is Frida.
I think it's
Haseen Frieda,
um,
some black guy from Africa who lives in Japan and he trains a soccer rob at
giant dude.
Right?
Tall motherfucker.
So we're watching this black dude destroy everybody while we're in the locker
room going,
Holy Shit.
This guy who's going to go against this dude,
he's probably about 210,
215 pounds.
Six foot four.
Haseen Frieda um,
this is the guy right here.
No,
no,
no.
The guy he's going to fight.
Yes.
Check.
Check out.
Check out this guy.
Shield in the hot scene.
Rida.
Yeah.
He just goes after legs and ripped.
He's tall,
dude.
He fucks people up.
So we're,
we're backstage watching this dude tear through.
That team is so much bigger than that guy.
Yeah,
totally.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
This is like a,
it looks like 150 pound guy versus a two o Fiverr.
Yeah.
And the way,
the way it is,
right.
So if you win the first match up,
right,
if there,
if there's not a submission,
it's submission only.
If there's not a submission and time runs out,
both those fighters are out.
It's whoever has the last fight or standing wins.
Right.
Oh Shit.
Look at this.
He goes right for legs and just rip them off,
Dude.
Yeah.
Looking for the other one now.
So much bigger than him.
So dangerous.
He let it go quick.
So anyways,
we're backstage watching this guy.
He tapped out like three days.
Can we see from Kenya,
maybe and Ghana,
Ghana and he trains over and download as well.
No,
no.
He lives in Japan.
He trains with uh,
somebody in Japan with soccer.
Raba you've got much bigger.
Yeah.
That's so crazy.
You guys a normal guy.
Yeah.
So at least it didn't hurt him.
So,
so if you win that first match,
you got to understand this.
This is how it goes.
Okay?
If you,
if you win,
you stay and you fight their second guy.
If you beat him again,
you stay and you fight their third guy to do the second or third guy already
fight.
Do they fight already?
Like you're not fighting a guy who hasn't fought.
Are you fighting a guy?
No.
No,
no,
no.
What happens is you win one five on five,
right?
This,
this is the first matchup right here,
right?
This guy wins.
Okay?
So that guy's out.
This guy stays in.
We still got five guys.
Now they got bore.
This guy fights this guy.
He wins again.
He taps him,
he stays and these guys haven't even fought yet.
And then this guy is gonna fight the third guy that people are listening here.
You got your fingers in the air.
No one was coming down.
The camera is yes we can.
So,
but if you tie,
let's say you're in a matchup and you tie both you guys are out and then the
next fight or comes in.
So it's the last man standing and um,
interested.
So it's a good idea.
Like Geo one against easy,
our smallest guy when against the biggest guy on the Turner,
right?
Judo,
Olympic Kamora of how,
so the strategy was there with just survive against the student,
knock them out.
Don't let them win because if he beats GL,
then he's gonna fight again.
He's going to keep fighting until he loses or gets a d points.
How's it work?
There's no points.
No submission.
Only submission.
Nolan.
And how much time do you have?
Uh,
it's,
I think it's eight minutes for regular matches,
but if it's a,
if there's a weight difference that,
uh,
like 40 pounds or more than it's a shorter match.
Okay.
Now when it's four minutes went against each sheet.
Yes.
Put on Gov Specie is she wasn't able to tap them,
which is incredible when you really think about how much bigger he is.
I mean he's a norm that it's the one after this one.
It's this the one after this fight I saw,
I saw Sakuraba and a Richie,
uh,
who we keep calling boogie and this is Richie right here against,
wow.
This is Richie.
He uh,
both these guys they got dqued because there was no taps.
A boogie had rubber guard all over and do it.
It looks scary.
So two or three times he got,
he got dqued as well.
They both happen.
Yeah,
they both get dqued if there's no submission,
which is beautiful.
It's a beautiful,
makes people go after things that both you guys are out.
It's whoever has the last fighter.
When,
um,
when I saw that soccer rabo was tapped out,
I was like,
who the fuck tapped out?
Sakuraba and then as he got off him,
I saw it was Richie.
I texted him,
I was like,
what the fuck?
Look at this.
Is He,
she and a GL right is so crazy.
This shit.
So it's all about GL is trying to attack them.
See Geo when for a Kamora of his own because he's really good at Camorra's.
So he was like,
fuck it,
I'm going to try to tap this guy out.
But it got to a point where he was just too big and he was,
he put a Kamora on GL and was just trying to rip his arm off.
Dude.
He had jeels arm behind his back.
I saw it,
I saw it and I,
I talked to Geo after the fact.
Geo and Richie came to see me,
uh,
in Temecula when I did,
the casino down there for Tonga.
Yeah.
I talked to him about it afterwards.
Went to that is,
he's like,
you didn't have me.
I'm like,
that's crazy.
It's crazy.
He couldn't tap you.
He's so much bigger.
And when I saw them yanking on his arm,
it's terrifying to watch.
He's like thinking about all the damage.
It's doing it,
that elbow and that shoulder.
Yup.
And he's trying to pass his guard and put a come moron.
You know,
he's got four minutes to do it.
So we're all thinking it would be great if Geo could tap this guy,
but at the very least,
knock him out.
You know what I mean?
Just survive.
Cause who knows?
He could've cleaned,
he'd get it cleaned out the whole team.
Look at this animal.
It's crazy.
This guy's a fucking monster.
Yeah.
I mean he keeps yanking on it too.
It's just amazing.
It gets crazy right here.
We're watching it,
right?
Boom.
Look at that.
Most people would have tapped right there a tapped look at that shit.
Boom.
Now he's good.
He got the hand down to the mat.
Luckily,
he's so good at Camorra's that he's created so many Kamora monsters down at a
school that he has to deal with gun wars all the time.
So that's why he was able to survive.
Look how he's getting his knees in.
See how he's,
he just creating space,
talking in again.
Yeah.
Amazing people who,
uh,
have never practiced you just who probably wouldn't appreciate how interesting
this technique that he has it on again.
So dangerous for him to do this,
to be stuck in a situation and to see she give up on it.
That's what's even more crazy.
Cause he,
she is literally a hundred pounds bigger.
He's going to go back to it.
But I mean he gave up on it right there though.
Yeah.
I mean he's so much bigger than them.
It's really,
it's sane.
So because of the fact there was no tap and this one,
both guys get knocked out as a how it goes.
We win there.
You know what I mean?
I took out a monster out the big gorilla.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
uh,
we win the first round and then we end up going against soccer robis team in the
finals because they beat a tighter muy Thai team.
Uh,
so now haseen Frieda
boogie taps out Sakharova he puts soccer Robyn and had Doris,
Doris and then he goes against,
he stays because he wins.
So he stays and he goes against Frieda and Frieda taps out book.
What did catch him with?
He got him with an arm bar and right there jeels next.
Now right here.
Here it is.
Yeah,
this is it.
This is where he gets buggy,
but boom.
So now he stays and jeels next and he's just on fire.
He's ripping through everybody.
And within a minute and how big is,
he said,
I just let her roll through here.
Let this role,
how big is he now it's like a g a,
he's about like six,
three,
six,
four tall.
I'm on the fuck to talk to 20 to 10 in that area.
So now look at,
this is GL against.
So I told Jill,
I said,
I looked at him,
dude,
to avenge your brother's loss.
I went fucking Kung,
cause I'm losing my mind.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
And and Geo is the final match.
No,
no,
no.
This is like right in the middle.
Now it's like there's three guys left each.
I don't understand there's this whole thing works,
but it's kind of confusing.
But once you,
once you stay in until you either lose or get 'em or at the draw if you lose or
to draw,
you're both out.
Um,
but if you win with a submission,
you stay and you fight the next guy.
One guy could,
could take out a whole team and you know,
um,
the winning team might have guys that did immediately attack,
like he's attacking.
Check is,
it doesn't last long.
So he's so tall,
he gls got one of the best guillotines in the system here.
Look,
boom.
He gets him right there before he stood up.
There was no way he would have been able to catch that front head lock.
And that's exactly what we're talking about.
Once you have a front headlock,
the Lil Nigga this,
he goes,
Marcella teen on him.
Boom.
All Marcella right here.
Check this out.
Boom.
Bam.
Right there.
Marcel is incredible,
man.
That is amazing.
That is an amazing kitty.
That 140 pound dude,
look at the tap out the elite high level,
210 pound dude like that.
That's incredible.
Maybe more than two 10.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
So Dude,
I'm on the side.
Losing my mind in my head almost exploded.
That's incredible.
So now GL stays and he goes against it.
Look at that size difference.
Look that shit,
guillotine,
guillotine that,
and if you want to,
the only way he was he could guillotine him was by almost sweeping them,
getting them on his butt,
and before he could stand up Cios,
he jumped on that head and arm boom,
and he sprawled them down,
snapped him down and turned it into a Marcella team.
Insane in Saint Louis too.
It's like,
oh no,
he thought it was going to be easy.
That's one to,
one of the more interesting things about Jujitsu,
Jujitsu is an art where a smaller person with technique really can't be a bigger
person.
And just Marcella teens are giant killers.
That's why it's in the,
we warm up with that shit,
dude.
We don't fuck around.
I mean I,
I don't know how many times you need to see Mark Marcella Garcia rip people
apart with those things before you put it into your,
your own system.
That's amazing.
So when is this event can happen again?
So we won this one.
It was super fucking crazy.
We won this one and um,
uh,
that was quintet to quintet three.
Uh,
we're returning and w that's going to be in Vegas the Friday before Conor versus
could beep oh,
so it's going to be a crazy weekend song.
They won the first quintet and they got Craig Jones.
They got Marcin.
How's that team Polaris,
I mean Craig Jones is one of the best grapplers in the world right now.
And um,
that's it.
Quintet.
I watched his match with who some are porous.
Uriah Faber got a team now.
Oh Shit.
There's geo boom.
Interesting.
And the Craig Jones,
that's fucking team.
Polaris was quintet one winter too.
It's really nice to see more people paying attention to submission grappling.
Maybe this is the way to do it.
This is your,
this is dude,
this is lighting the world on the grappling world,
on fire.
Every one starting their own quintet rules as a new thing.
Now.
They've already been,
that happened to a month and half ago and they've already been tournaments.
Quit Blue Belt Quintet Tournament.
Like we're having a quintet tournament.
At the 10th planet eclipse,
which is what we all get together once a year and have a party and you know,
um,
and uh,
do business stuff like a business summit meeting is founded by Josh Barnett.
Is that what you're saying?
He's in it.
John.
John Edson it,
he had,
he was in the first one,
but it's a Sakharova shame.
No.
Quintec three card will feature soccer.
Rob Himself in action along with fell UFC hall of Famer,
Uriah Faber,
former UFC heavyweight champion,
Josh Barnett and elite glass grappling champions,
including three times Ebi winner,
Geo motherfucking Martinez and raining campy,
I guess Josh Byrne had it would be in this one.
Craig Jones.
That's awesome man.
Maybe he's not,
maybe he's on soccer,
Robin's team or something.
I don't know.
You know what man,
he's like real ambivalent about his is not ambivalent,
but you know,
he's just trying to figure out what he's going to do with his career.
He's been released by the UFC.
You know,
he had that whole Usada thing where,
um,
it was a,
they flagged him for,
was it a tainted supplement?
He went over the whole story on the podcast.
It was a tainted supplement.
They proved it was a tainted supplement.
Um,
they released him but it took a long time to do so and he was very frustrated by
it and now he's not sure what he's going to do.
So for him to do something like this,
you know,
especially like at this stage of his career,
like Josh is still an elite grappler.
Absolutely.
One the worlds in the g tap dean lister out.
Remember that tap dean lister out with a cat was account.
No,
no,
it was a scarf.
Hold scarf,
hold show,
forget.
I forget.
Yeah,
it was like a one of them judo side.
Headlock chokes.
I mean tapped out here on Grayson.
I mean he had,
he had a lot of weight on them but still he's still got them.
The Dean lister one is,
both of them are incredibly impressive,
but the dean lister is a big guy.
You know dean lister and him are of similar size.
Yeah.
So he got him in,
he got him inside control and then he went to like one of those.
Remember when Mark Coleman tapped out,
Dan Severn the front of that.
It's like a,
just a regular school start.
Hold the headlock I got put in a headlock ones is as a kid for being an asshole.
I couldn't get out.
I couldn't get out man.
You realize how fucking good Josh is though.
When you see him control a guy like dean lister,
I mean that's how God damn good.
That's according to be quarter.
Nelson record is pop off.
These shameless popups.
These wants done with it.
Someone screen recorded.
Oh,
someone's screen in cornea.
That was a shameless pop on.
All right,
we're good.
Um,
so that's fucking interesting.
Who else is on the car this weekend?
Pull up the UFC card this weekend.
So it was Darren tail versus Tyron Woodley.
I'm very excited by that fight.
We look,
Darren till is a really,
really high level striker.
Like the way he moves way he sets things up,
the strategies.
He does fight with his chin up in the air though.
And he does fight with his hands down low,
but it's to invite in brawls.
Um,
so who else we got?
We got,
oh,
Montana and voluntariness shift.
Chanko Woo.
The beat is fighting.
Oh Shit.
Well up beat was supposed to be fighting Yahya Rodriguez,
but Yahya Rodriguez got injured.
So Brandon Davis took it on real short notice,
I think like less than three weeks notice.
And that's going to be a good fight,
right?
Yeah.
Jessica and dried it.
Probably had the biggest arms in the women's division.
She least do.
Those arms are incredible.
Yeah.
I'm really excited about tilling Woodley.
That's the fight that's most interesting to me.
That one to me it's like,
ah,
I watched that.
The Woodley till highlights and I'm like,
I don't know man.
I'm real interested about this because what,
what till brings to the game is a size and height and distance and striking.
But what Tyron Woodley,
[inaudible] Woodley also has wrestling also his championship experience.
Been there,
done that
tils favorite?
Yeah,
one 45 to one 25 I never understood that.
How can they both be slightly above a hundred last to do with the money,
but yeah,
I know,
but I mean still like wait a minute.
So if you know one of them's,
you bet a hundred you went in one and a half,
but the other one is also favorite.
No one 25 I mean one 25 so that you,
so okay,
so what it is,
is Darren tills favorite by one 45 like if you bet a hundred you wouldn't one 45
that means you have to pay a hundred.
If you win a hundred,
right?
You have to pay one 45 to 100 where if you bet a hundred you wouldn't one 25 on
Woodley who is the champion.
Correct.
That has really just like if you bet now,
because this will change probably by all the way up to time to fight starts
normally and I stand this marijuana don't understand it.
I understand it,
but we smoked too much pot before this show.
The um,
the thing that's interesting to me is that he,
he doesn't,
I don't understand why they would have him a favorite unless there's a lot of
money coming in from Liverpool.
Literally would just what it is.
It's just attending favor.
It's not like this isn't saying the fair for the site.
Just like there should be an expert line.
I go,
I wonder what the expert line would be because he like,
if I didn't work for the UFC,
if I'm standing here and you say,
what do you,
who do you think wins his fight?
I'd have to step back if I was like working for a casino,
if they hired me as a consultant,
I'd say this is a pick him fight.
Anything can happen in this fight.
There's no way I know what's going to happen in this fight.
Like the vow,
here's what fight Valentina Shevchenko and Nico Montana,
that that fight should be like 1200 to one.
That's pretty much what it is.
It 1600 1600 okay,
well I'm being conservative.
Another other one is on drought or uh,
just the beat is minus 1200 yeah,
that makes sense to those two.
Make Sense.
See this one to me is like,
hmm.
I don't know.
I really do not know.
That's,
that is very much like pick them territory.
You could even have it.
Like it could be plus one 10 plus.
So this could vary depending upon like we'll late Woodley money could come in or
late til money could shifted even higher.
I think some,
I don't know,
depending on how much is really on it,
someone could change that part.
I like a $10,000 bet they could flip it or something like that.
It depends on how much is currently writing.
It's a,
it's a very interesting fight.
I think.
Um,
one factor is going to be kicks and I think you will,
you're going to see is tilled doing a lot of what he did in the Wonderboy fight,
which is a attack that lead leg with the front leg side kick.
He does that a lot and it's a,
it's an awful kick if you get hit with it.
Hyper extends your knee and um,
he does it really well.
It's a real controversial kick.
I mean,
I don't know really it should be,
if it's legal to grab your leg in a heel hook and rip it apart.
Why isn't it legal?
The side kick your leg.
I mean I don't think it's dirty at all.
The thing is that you can't,
the idea is that you can't tap from it Darren till a profit back from the
pisser.
Uh,
Darren till is a,
he's known for this.
Uh,
in the,
in the wonder why Friday through these hard front lake side kicks to the knee
just like Robert Whitaker did to Yoel Romero and just like Yoel Romero did to
him and a previous fight like that front leg side kick to the knee is become a
big kick and tells really good at it.
I think that's going to be a big factor in this fight is distance.
Like if till can keep his distance and uses reach,
you know cause it says that the same reach but that doesn't make any sense but
doesn't one of them is taller you mean it's just like yeah maybe the arm
distance is the same but as Woodley generally counter fight as he generally kind
of stepping back.
I mean is he going to want to be done a lot of that?
He does a lot of that.
He's really good at countering a heel.
He lets himself almost get pushed back to the cage and then launch launches
forward.
If you watch like when he Kao Josh Koscheck what he does,
he would let,
he almost let guys press him up against the cage and they expose themselves and
the need tax back.
Rory Macdonald figured out a way to nullify that he was the like,
but that was also a different Tyron Woodley cause I was tired of Willie before
Duke Roufus see most people don't realize that even though Tyler and Rudy was
like world class one of the best welterweights on the planet,
he was really kind of training himself who's working with different people all
over the country.
But he didn't have a main head coach.
He didn't get one until he started training with two goofus.
So from Duke Roufus on,
it's like you're looking at a different fighter.
He's much better at like relaxing,
conserving his energy.
He doesn't get tired in the later rounds anymore.
He's much more effective.
And he also knows not to get sucked in by the crowd.
Like in the Wonderboy fights in particular,
like people were saying it's boring,
but you have to fight Wonderboy.
That way you can't charge at them.
If you charge it wonderful,
you get lit up,
you get lit up with these crazy counterstrikes.
You got to wait for Wonderboy to lead.
And Wonderboy was leading and Tyron still again,
Wonderboy landed more shots,
but Tyron hurt him way more.
How do the Kelvin gasoline them fight?
Go with Woodley.
It was a split decision beat Calvin by decision.
It was,
you know,
pretty,
pretty close fight.
But Calvin,
that was the fight.
We're Kelvin didn't make weight.
He was all fucked up coming into that fight,
but a Woodley one.
But that was also,
uh,
want to say that was like right when he started with Duke or maybe start with
Duke after that.
Um,
either way you look a little like the Robbie Lawler fight is a good example.
What he can do,
what would we can do is put the best guys in the world out with one shot guys
who nobody puts out.
Who the fuck puts out Robbie Lawler.
Robbie Lawler gets hit with bombs and survives and Tyron Woodley put one on him,
knocked him out.
I mean he can do that to anybody and he could do that to Darren till two.
I mean if Darren till doesn't think that coming into this fight because he's the
more accomplished Stryker.
It's a very dangerous fight for them.
Woodley so fucking fast.
But then again Darren till can find his rhythm,
establishes distance and start using those kicks in particular that front leg
side kick man,
he fucks your leg up with that and then his leg kicks and then his leg kicks
with combinations and he also,
he's real creative with his striking.
There's a lot of hand movement.
There's a lot to distract you.
Maybe Woodley's best strategy would be to just take him down over and over again
and try to mount them and try to take us back and and trying to do some ground
and Parallon.
Look man,
he's a stress test to take down.
I don't know.
It's a good question.
And how,
how is he on his back?
That's a good question too.
You know what we know about him is he likes a strike.
Big Tall Dude likes to strike nasty striker.
You know,
one of the more impressive things that he did is not the knockout of cowboy,
but when he hit him with that elbow,
he hit him with his step in elbow where I was like,
Jesus,
the speed of it man.
It's like the,
the smoothness of his closing,
the distance and the speed of landing that elbow.
Like he showed cowboy different distances and then he,
he like,
he left this opening for that elbow and he slides in and cracks him with it and
you're like,
oh Jesus.
Like here's him against cowboy.
Like see how his hands are down low.
He's got a lot of movement of his hands but the like that jab comes up from the
bottom,
comes from like underneath.
You don't know like until it's too late,
whether he's just probe a new or whether he's punching you.
There's a lot of that,
see a lot of that with the hands
and he keeps his chin straight up in the air,
but he also is really good at moving his head back.
He's also really used to high level sparring and high level fighting.
He's an elite guy man,
and a dangerous kind of weird style and a lot of ways.
There's a lot,
see all that hand movement and Shit like he does a lot of that shit that you saw
on Bruce Lee movies.
Yeah.
Well watching.
Look at this boom to the body.
I mean that's,
that's nasty,
right?
Like you start thinking it's coming over the top and it comes to the body.
Have you heard another loranges impersonation of,
of done until it's hilarious.
You know and I though it was fucking talented.
God Man,
he's a talented guy.
The,
the MMA world is lucky that we have him.
It's fucking,
it was talk about like hilarious inside shit in the world of Jujitsu and MMA,
like his fake feud with Vinnie Mag.
Allays is hilarious.
That's a real feud,
man.
They hate each other and trust.
We're on,
we're on a group text me Vinny and not,
and they're just constantly fucking tearing each other apart constantly.
That's hilarious.
They hate each other.
That's so funny,
man.
V Vinnie Mongolia is doing good.
He's doing great,
but what does that Pfl yeah,
having a watching that.
Yeah.
I watched fight.
He won by head kick,
knock out.
I was like,
Oh shit.
All of a sudden you got to worry about his head kick is that may be his third
head kick knock out.
Well you definitely have to worry about it.
And his Jujitsu is top of the food chains and now he's like really into it and
wanting to throw it,
wanting to set it up more.
There's being,
being hits him with that left hand.
Watch this
boom.
And then as he closes in,
wash his elbow,
he's closing.
Dang right there.
Ooh,
that's so nasty.
That is a fucking hard elbow man.
Does he remind you of Connor a little bit?
The way he kind of stands.
It seems like they kind of have that same style.
Well,
they have a similar style and that they have their hands spread apart and you
know,
constantly fainting and lot of bouncing up and down and back and forth.
A lot of movement.
Yeah.
He's not unlike a plotting guy.
What did he do it on his feet?
Did he do karate growing up or something?
Like a lot of more times he was a kid,
very young.
I'd have to ask Vinny shoreman the full,
uh,
full background of him.
But you know,
Vinny,
Vinny was one of the ones who told me about them like a long time ago and told
me about him when he's first fight in the UFC.
He's like,
you gotta Watch this guy.
He's fucking special.
And he said,
uh,
you know his Liverpool accident cause finished from Liverpool to,
he said,
uh,
when the cowboy fight was going on,
he's like,
cowboy doesn't know what he's in for.
Like he thinks he's just going to go in there and fight this guy and doesn't
need to watch tape on him.
Like you have no idea where you're dealing with what's cowboy a hundred percent
and that fight.
Did he have some weight cutting issues?
One 70 and it was one 70 to be trained properly for that fight.
I mean,
I assume he did.
He's not saying,
oh now I don't know.
You know,
it's just,
I think cowboy honestly as a one 50 fiver or one 60 fiber,
you know,
I think there's a lot of fighters that are like that.
I mean,
I think cowboy can beat real top guys like Matt Brown.
He'd be beat Matt Brown at one and he got beat guys at one 70 no doubt.
But I just think the re realistically these guys at one 70 are so fucking big
that cowboys more of a one 55 or,
yeah.
But I think that even one 55 hurts them,
hurts him to get down there.
So He's a tweener,
you know,
like Diego Sanchez always been kind of a tweener,
it's like too small for one seven eight too big for one 55 yeah.
You know,
but Diego made it down to one 45 once.
That's crazy.
That doesn't sane.
That's that iron will son Bj to,
he did it on 71 55 one 45 I did heavyweight.
Remember we thought Leo Machida machine.
It was like two oh five and Bj just ate whatever the fuck he wanted.
I didn't even step on a scale,
be chased back.
He's gonna Fight Ryan Hall.
That's going to be interesting.
That's whole fight.
That's good fight because Ryan Hall,
although he's got good kicks and he's,
he's good at keeping guys in the outside.
He's very smart.
It using his kicks to set up his Jujitsu.
You know people who had criticized it got a lot to Yup,
he does.
That's an interesting fight.
That's that.
You know,
you don't want to see like the higher would drag.
This one was tough to watch.
Yeah.
Cause you're watching Bj fight.
A young guy who has a specialty that's like not in Bj's wheelhouse.
Like Bj's never been really a kicker.
You know like he kicked Diego Sanchez and the head remember open up that big
cut.
It was like one of the only head kicks you ever saw Bj throw in his whole
career.
Bj has been more punching in wrestling and Jujitsu,
but he's fun.
Yeah.
Ear like your ears like him and Zach beat like that.
Those tall guys with crazy kicks.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Those are so hard to deal with man.
And Bj just,
it was the wrong fight for them.
It's just not a good fight.
Didn't make any sense.
It's hard to watch.
Watch,
watch him get three 60 roundhouse kicked in the head.
You're like,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Years striking is just,
that's why I'm so bummed out that he got hurt.
Yogurt versus a beat would have been crazy.
That would have been crazy.
That's the probably the craziest striking match up.
I'm being,
well real mean one of crazier strikes than yeah,
year.
Nobody is on beat.
Can throw all that same shit.
Yeah.
But yeah,
you're just cartwheel kicks
consistently at a high frequency.
Just keeps telling him.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
The thing about him though,
it was a,
like when you watch the Frankie Edgar fight,
you're like,
hmm,
okay,
that can be shut down.
Like that can be really shut down.
Like he didn't have an answer when it was shut down.
So He's,
which means in my mind that his game is so heavily favored,
that looseness openness and kicking ass kicking crazy,
uh,
you know,
wild kicking that he,
it's,
it's imbalanced,
right?
In the sense that he's got to put almost the same amount of effort to fighting
off of his back.
If he put the,
if he developed a,
an unbelievable guard game,
the match has unbelievable kicking game.
Holy Shit mean then you'd have an incredible balance messing around.
Rubber going,
I better yet you should look,
it makes sense when you the best,
the best kickers.
Like,
like that's one of the things that pedis is realizing now.
Pedis has kind of stopped concentrating so much on wrestling and he said,
what I got to get back to doing is fighting.
And when I'm at my best,
he was saying is using his striking.
And then when it goes to the ground,
trying to submit,
people don't try to stop,
take downs,
don't try to take people down.
Forget all that.
So he's going back to what got him there.
You think about like,
is Benson Henderson fight won by arm bar?
I mean,
uh,
Gilbert Melendez,
fi wins by Ikea teen takes,
takes his time on the feet,
does all his creative shit on the feet.
But if someone takes him down,
he tried to submit him,
immediately jumps on shit.
I think that's the,
that's a,
an interesting combination,
you know,
that's why I'm so interested in that fight with him and Tony because Tony so
wild.
Yeah.
Tony does the same thing.
The one thing you got to watch,
watch out with Tony's.
Uh,
he has so much firepower from so many different angles on the ground,
but I mean,
he,
he knows,
he knows a lot,
a lot.
There's much he could
tap you with,
but his Darce game is so high level and he could get it from so many angles that
really,
I think the most dangerous thing would be,
uh,
you know,
our guys that are just focused on one thing.
And especially since he hits those Darcis from every goddamn angle,
you know,
if he came out and just said,
whatever happens,
we're always looking for the dark.
He was in trouble in that,
uh,
Lando Vanatta fight and boom,
you just put them in a Darson that saved the day.
You know what I mean?
So there's,
there's a lot of different ways Tony could make you tap on the ground.
Trust me,
he knows so much,
but man,
if he just stuck with is Doris game,
man,
that's probably the most dangerous way to go on the ground.
You know,
it's an interesting fine man.
Interesting fight.
You know,
pet,
this is a nasty kicker.
There's a lot of great things in that fight.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
that's not,
that's on that card.
That card.
Is that on the same card?
It's on copy.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
What else is on that car?
Pull up that Conor Khabib card.
Who else was fighting on that card?
Do you know?
It's only a month away.
I don't know.
It's not top of my head.
I know.
Sugar shut up.
You put up the,
yeah,
I like Sean O'malley fights in the main event.
He's a fun dude.
Man.
Had them in here.
We got barbecued separate.
Oh,
Derrick.
Derrick Lewis.
Alexander Volkov.
Oh,
that's an interesting fight.
That Volkov guy might be the dark horse.
He might be the guy in the heavyweight division waiting in the wings,
you know,
karate hottie versus Felicia is going to be good.
Oh,
mount.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
Um,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm interested in the Ferguson fight for sure.
The pedes Ferguson fight,
but I telling you that this is back Louis Volkov fight,
man.
That one.
I'm like,
Huh?
That Volkov Guy.
Did you see what he did it for a reseal for doom.
When you watched that fight,
you go,
oh Jesus Christ.
I in fact I could do that.
He,
he,
he stopped for breezy over doom.
He'd beat the shit out of him before he stopped him.
Who's the Russian guy who puts dudes in Ezekiel choke while he's being mounted?
Who's that?
Duly Nick.
Right back guys pulling nick mounted.
Zeke you'll students everywhere from why he's being mounted.
And John Jack does that too.
That is so crazy.
But to do that in MMA with the gloves on,
it's like an unheard of.
Unbelievable.
While being mounted,
putting people to sleep.
That's just like,
what do you think you're ever gonna see that again?
I think he has the ability to do it.
No,
but I mean from other people.
Do you think that would be something that he just start adopting if fighters put
the time in,
you know all submissions or are possible.
You just got to put a lot of time at it.
You got to get obsessed with it.
It's like,
wow,
ooh.
What are the odds of that one working a lot.
One
guy's been able to pull it off.
Who else has been in what?
He does it multiple times.
I've seen him do it twice.
Yeah,
twice.
I've seen it.
I've,
I haven't seen the third one,
but I've seen two of them standing gear in chokes.
So who got a standing gear teen?
This is a five minute compilation of,
I don't know.
There's a lot of them.
Oh,
standing good teens.
Yeah,
but this,
this is not what we're talking about though.
We're talking about,
it's called the Zeke.
You'll mounted to Zq.
Jamie's just make up some Russians over here.
Stephanie,
pretty common.
E,
z.
Z,
e k e l isn't a zeal to the dude from the Bible.
It is the guy from the Bible.
The saw the UFO.
Oh yeah.
That was the first ever one in the UFC and the UFC.
Yes,
but but a Zeke,
you'll chokes in MMA.
Just Google.
Ezekiel,
chokes and MMA.
What's the guy's name?
Maybe that's the only one that's up.
The top five videos are just him doing it.
Oh,
he's done it more than how many times he's done it taught him.
the same fight.
Oh,
the one fight put play it just so we watched it again.
It's pretty crazy.
It's crazy that someone can figure out a way to do something that no one has
ever done before in 2018 so he's gets the headlines and then he's just holding
on and then he slides it in deeper and then this dude's fucked tap and that is
so crazy.
Yeah,
that is so crazy.
He just clinches on your head.
Then I do look so disappointed.
He was like,
how the fuck did I get that?
He just clinches on that bag.
And then just the slips it in Saudi had this one in the bag [inaudible] full
mountain.
It's already got this mother fucker and format.
Yeah,
he's gonna be,
he's thinking about the after party and everything.
Yeah,
Alexi Oli.
Nick.
That's a bad motherfucker.
It's interesting how many people that we're seeing right now from Russia,
you know,
from the former Soviet Union,
eastern bloc countries.
It's really amazing.
I mean,
it's a beat.
Norma Madoff.
Um,
you know,
you can keep going down the line.
There's so many of these guys that are coming up.
It's really a what?
A hotbed of talent,
especially Dagestan and how many bad motherfuckers come out of Dagestan.
Yeah.
It's a beef versus,
I mean,
I'm hubby versus Connor.
Like Holy Shit.
Is that fight interesting.
What the fuck is going to happen?
It really happens.
You don't,
is going to happen.
Don't say that son of a bitch.
I'll get them there.
I mean,
how weird is it looking at Conor with no belt cubby with the belt?
I mean forever could be just trying to get a shot at that belt.
Yeah.
And the way he wanted.
Okay.
Crazy shit.
Setting up this fight.
This fight is a fucking interesting fight,
man,
because if Connor can't stop that down,
does he go the way of everybody else?
Does he get mauled the way everybody else got mall?
Does he get mauled the way?
Michael Johnson got mauled z get mauled the way Dasan hills.
You still sign?
Yours got mauled.
Uh,
Chandler.
Oh,
not Chandler.
A Johnson.
Michael Johnson.
Yeah,
we said Johnson.
Edson Barboza and then he got mauled.
The Way Barboza got mauled was scary because like halfway into the first round
could Biebs taking them down and you see Barboza just taking a deep breath like
this.
I like realizing like,
oh no.
Yeah,
like what in the fuck is all this about?
It's worse than I imagined.
Yeah.
This is just a completely different,
they really,
I mean,
no doubt Connor probably has the heaviest hands in the game.
Pound for pound,
no doubt,
but take down defense and fighting off your back.
That has nothing to do with the power.
It's not,
it doesn't translate.
And also what is it going to look like?
Is his take down defense better than Michael Johnson's?
Is his take down defense better than Edson Barboza or quinto who's a wrestler.
Yeah.
I mean our stuffed his takedowns a couple times in the first round.
But you know,
the persistence is a really good wrestler.
Yeah.
And how,
how good is Connors?
It's good question man.
He would,
if he gets what?
He gets tired,
what if he gets taken down easier than all those other guys?
You don't know.
Right.
You know what I mean?
He's got Dylan Dannis in his corner.
Dylan is a,
I think he wrestled in high school and um,
I'm not too sure.
I brought in some Olympic caliber wrestler for his camp.
Who did?
Connor brought in some,
uh,
some super high level wrestler.
First camp.
Uh,
famous one.
Yeah.
James can find it.
A UFC fighter.
I don't believe he's a UFC fighter.
Say it again.
It does it say that.
Does he offered to help him?
I don't know if that's what you're really brought it.
I don't know who we brought in.
Um,
but I know that there was some talk about him bringing in some super high level
wrestler.
Jordan Burroughs is not working with Connor,
which is,
that might be who you're talking about.
Could be,
well that would be one who you would want to work with you.
That would be someone who you would get asked.
But Jordan Burroughs is probably fucking busy.
And has he expressed an interest in fighting and MMA?
Because if he does,
there's a lot of people that are fucked.
He tweeted out on the 13th of August,
I'm not working with Connor.
I'm attempting to win a world championship of my own in October.
It doesn't say wrestling.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
so he,
yeah,
that's what I was thinking.
Like he probably doesn't have time to help someone with a camp like that.
Especially if they could.
This point is,
you know he's taken off right now if he ever decides to go into MMA like yeah,
yeah,
I wonder what's going to happen in that fight him man,
I just don't know whether or not Khabib is going to be able to close the
distance without getting hit with a,
Connor's going to be able to stay on the outside long enough where it could,
Khabib is going to come at him like with reckless abandon the way he did with
Edson Barboza and he just stormed after Barboza just walked him down.
Yeah.
Well is he gonna be able to do that with Connor or is he going to clip coming
in?
I mean,
is he going to be able to fade?
That left hand is going to be able to stop that and if Konica just keep him from
taking them a couple of times in the first round,
just a couple of times.
Just enough to put a little bit of doubt,
get a little bit of that shit talk and going and land a couple of good punches.
Or does Khabib just grab them early?
Ragdoll Boehm side control,
elbows punched neon belly punch,
punch,
elbow punch.
Do we just see a mauling?
It's interesting.
You know it's,
it could go either way.
Like I see both I this,
this one of those weird fights where I don't know what the fuck's going to
happen,
but I don't think we're going to see like some crazy drawn out five round fight.
I definitely could be wrong,
but I think we're going see like one person dominate,
whether it's whoever figures out how to impose their game,
whether it's Conor can dominate on the feed.
Our Khabib can dominate on the ground.
You think that'll be the biggest paper view ever?
It's going to be huge.
It's going to be so big that's going to be so good and not be the biggest one
will be giant it hunters the biggest star.
Right?
The only thing it's going to hold it back as mainstream knowledge of it because
there's not a lot of press because Connor's not doing a lot of stuff.
It's not like in the news a lot.
Like,
how many of these regular people know that Connor is going to fight?
You never see it on Instagram,
Macy and her files you have see pages.
If you and I see it,
you and I see a we fall MMA pages.
But fuck man.
Is Khabib doing interviews?
Does he taught them?
I have no idea.
I don't.
No.
That means no man.
If you don't know.
Yeah,
I don't know what meeting shit.
I haven't seen much.
I mean I've seen some video footage of him training at Aka.
The whole thing's crazy man.
So,
so I mean I'm,
I'm just,
I'm crossing toes and causing everything.
Just please let this one go down please.
I can't imagine someone getting injured.
I'd be so,
I wouldn't mind if someone got injured.
I'd be so sad.
Well you wouldn't because Tony,
but jumping in with a tray and it's still going to be a great fight.
So the way,
fine.
Either way,
the guaranteed there's going to be some serious shit.
Either Tony Versus Khabib.
Tony versus Connor or controversy could be.
I think Tony is one of the more dangerous fights for Connor because first of all
is durability,
is endurance is crazy.
He's ability to fight from anywhere.
Can he fights real good?
Standing up,
he puts a pace on you,
doesn't mind getting hit,
always walking,
walk forward.
Always walking forward,
walking people down.
If you hit him,
you can hit him and hurt him.
Doesn't matter.
He survived.
He's rives finds a way to survive and one little scramble clench on the ground
and there's a Darce right there.
I don't know if the landowner Vanatta [inaudible] is totally fair because I,
you know,
I mean people look at that and they'll go,
well it is fair.
But I mean,
I think that was a last minute fight.
Am I right?
He didn't really have a training camp for that one.
I don't know if it was because it was a last minute fight or he does believe it
was last minute.
Um,
he was,
I'm not too sure.
All I know,
I don't know what happened in the net training camp,
but it wasn't a legit training camp for Tony,
but almost not making excuses.
But that's,
that's what happened also.
What else?
One of the reasons why,
I don't know if you could look at that,
if it was like people were looking at the right way,
because I think Lando is way more talented than people give them credit for
because I can't,
I think so too.
Yeah.
I think in,
in moments,
in his fights,
he's just brilliant.
Yeah.
And I think then he gets tired sometimes and he has moments where he fades off
and then moments where he's in these crazy wild slug fests,
like the Bobby Green fights,
a great example of that,
that,
that in the,
you've watched the first round,
the first round,
he looks smooth as silk man.
I mean,
he just looks fantastic.
It looks like a world beater,
but he tapers off.
He fades a little bit.
And uh,
I don't know what that is.
You know,
I'm not,
I'm not sure what's causing them to fade,
but I think that at his best,
when he hits those real high notes like he did in the Tony Fight,
he's fucking dangerous,
man.
Anybody sleeps on,
Lando is in real trouble.
He's super athletic.
He does wild shit.
He's real creative and knocked out.
John McKenzie with a fucking wheel kick.
I mean,
whoa.
He do.
He does wild shit man.
And he moves good dude.
He's got an interesting kind of way of moving and he's not afraid to scrap heal
and that,
that not being afraid to scrap makes him dangerous but also makes him
vulnerable,
which I think is cost him a little bit.
But I think a big one is the endurance.
You know this some,
there's some people out there like I'm the guy that's working with Tj Dillashaw.
Um,
what is his name?
The guy down in uh,
southern California down near San Diego.
Um,
Colivida.
Is that his name?
What does he teach?
It's strength and conditioning coaches.
What's his name?
I don't know.
I'll text TJ.
See I just googled Tj Dillashaw new strength and conditioning program.
These guys like the nick curse on and the Sam [inaudible],
Sam,
Kavita,
that guy was,
he,
if you watched the preparation videos for TJ getting ready for coding Dillashaw
you see him doing all his wild shit,
man.
Everyone's doing all these explosive crazy movements.
Just like back when,
um,
uh,
we saw TJ when w we saw,
um,
when Bj was at his best when I'm Marinovich was training him.
And you know,
curse on comes from,
that's cool too.
You know that learning under the Marinovich has but that kind of crazy
plyometric cha training all its explosive shit that they're doing box jumps and
crazy things with medicine balls and slamming things and chat back and forth and
back and forth.
These guys getting phenomenal shape man.
And I think that's imperative today.
I think today it's almost like,
it's not when,
when guys are getting ready for a fight,
and this is one of the thing that nick curse on it said it's you already know
how to fight.
Like literally everything should be focused on your gas tank.
Like you only have six weeks have you don't know how to fight and you're not
gonna learn in six weeks,
you know how to fight.
Six weeks should be just crazy gas tank work.
And when he gets guys like,
like dos Anjos when he fought cowboy,
when he gets ahold of guys and,
and you see that style,
like when dos Anjos fought pedis when he's got that incredible kind of cardio
that's so hard to fuck with man.
Yeah.
You know,
the pommel horse,
is that how you say it?
The pommel horse pommel one of those things.
Well in order to,
um,
to do that,
you have to do this exercise where you put your feet,
there's like a,
like a chain hanging and it's got like a weightlifting belt and you put your
feet in your ankles and you start doing it on that and it just spins like,
oh wow.
And Tony's obsessed with it.
Nobody can do it.
Like Jeremiah,
Jeremy Chai,
I bring in a bunch of 10 plan of black belts in and no one can even kind of do
it,
do it.
Seems like Gian Real.
But he,
he hasn't come to Tony's camp.
He's,
he's two hours away.
It's,
it's too hard for them.
But um,
and those guys,
cause they're breakdancing background.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
that's what he's,
he's really getting into gymnastics right now.
Tony.
He's,
he's trying to take his fighting.
Well that was giant for George Saint Pierre with GSP started getting in
gymnastics,
you know,
and uh,
watching my daughter do it and watching like the amount of physical strength it
takes to do like handsprings backflips and all that stuff.
All that.
It's all explosion.
Yeah.
Being able to control yourself on the bars and the rings and the,
the amount of physical strength that you have to have to be able to do that,
that,
that applies directly to Jujitsu.
I'm thinking about putting some gymnastics equipment up.
I got rings already.
Oh really?
A rings in the bounce shit.
You think you're going to try to bring iron man or what's it called?
Iron Cross.
I don't know if I could do that.
I'm too fat.
I call it out like that.
I Dunno man.
But it's great.
It's great to like,
um,
for rotation,
like as you're doing a chin up,
you know about grabbing it like this.
And then as you're,
as you're two and a chin up,
rotating in.
So I rotate my arms with the rings as I'm doing Chin ups.
I liked that a lot.
I feel like it gives me more of a range of motion and just a bar.
I like doing chin ups on the bar too.
But I think that especially like as I get older,
like range of motion is very important to not lose that.
I see a lot of people,
they lose their range of motion cause they're not working on the stretching,
the not working on do they do a lot of meatheads shit and they don't work on
keeping their mobility at a high level.
You know?
That's why another thing that I like is stretching out in the sauna.
You have a stretch out in the sauna.
Man,
haven't done a signup thing and in a while and you telling me once I'm come by
we'll have some fun conversations in the sauna but getting in the sauna man and
just,
you get super heated up and then just start stretching out like everything's
loose and warmed up and you can just pull things into better positions and just
give everything like a stretch.
Just to keep doing hot yoga all the time.
I love it.
I gotta get back into it now.
Now,
now that my shoulders,
I think my shoulder could hang with yoga right now.
I think I just don't have any pressure on it.
You want to go with me?
Come with me and my class.
Let's do it.
What days do you go?
Didn't too early.
It depends.
Yeah,
I do.
I like early,
early.
I don't want to say,
I'll tell you I've got 600 people show up.
5:00 AM Oh no,
no.
Go into the dark dude.
That's what's up.
We'll do that coon Delaney.
Fuck that.
Go to downtown La to a place for Denny.
Used to go that Cuny,
you know,
get that DMT trip like four in the morning type shit.
Crazy head Bang John Shit.
Headbanging I've heard about it.
Yeah.
Next serious headbanging like Metallica style.
Headbanging just too many people that say that you could trip balls for it to
not be trying to shake out the DMT demons.
Can I get dean was
a,
what'd you get out of here?
Anything else?
Anything else going on?
Uh,
Ebi 17 coming up September 29.
Can I in in three weeks be in Toronto at a Mussel farm,
Hbcu and Burbank.
It's going to be the first 16 man,
Twitter permanently bands,
Alex Jones and info wars accounts.
Tom,
um,
he counts.
Violated the company's abusive behavior policies.
Twitter said it in a series of tweets.
The band comes weeks after Jones was banished.
Suspended.
Well Anyway,
September 29th is a 16 man,
16 man Combat Jujitsu.
So Ebi just turning into Chris's downtown la again.
No,
no,
this is a muscle farm.
HBCU and Burbank.
Oh,
beautiful facility.
That's an amazing place.
Oh yeah.
It's dude.
Um,
Jesse tailors in it from the UFC.
A three time black belt world champion.
Phillipa Focalin is in it.
Um,
uh,
one of my,
one of the fastest rising 10 planet stars,
John Thor Blank is in it.
Cal Chambers,
who's also one of the best 10 plan of guys coming up.
Uh,
it's,
it's going to be a slap fast man.
Slap fat too.
If you haven't seen it is a Eddie Bravo's invention and it's fuck,
it's the,
the best gap between grappling and MMA training as far as I'm concerned.
Thank you man.
My man.
Ah,
Fun Times.
Thanks for doing this today.
We will have Daniel Cormier yon eventually he fucked up.
Can I plug a couple of comedy?
Yeah.
Niagara Falls,
tinfoil hat,
comedy at Niagara Falls,
September,
1415 and then,
uh,
Philly October 12,
Syracuse,
October 14th and Houston,
November 3rd.
Austin.
Just tell him,
don't have to forget this.
Eddie Bravo 10 P on Instagram.
On Instagram.
Thank you.
And Toronto.
We're moving that of venue.
It was supposed to be the Ricoh Coliseum.
Now it's going to be the Scotia Bank arena.
It was both the union.
It's because of a union dispute.
We talked about this before.
I'm not crossing into union picket lines.
So we moved to a new venue in the new venue is also,
yeah,
it's bigger,
but it's also a union venue.
Uh,
it's just that they don't have a problem with their contract or it's not,
you know,
not the same dispute.
So I think it's the same union in fact.
But when we go,
when everybody from the old tickets gets their new tickets,
then we'll sell.
There's 1200 more tickets for this new place cause that'd be within the next
couple of days.
I'm hoping.
All right,
Joe rogan.com for all that shit.
Bye.
Thank you.